uh sorry i lost track of the loops i don't know what loop we
are in anymore sorry i was like i'm all over the place today
guys i i'm all over the place right now guys i'm so quiet i
forgot that my cleaner the cleaner comes at 10 a.m today it
was not a smart idea um it was not sorry my brain's so
frazzled right now it's not a smart idea that um i had my
cleaner come in at 10 a.m and i streamed onimusha for six
plus hours starting at 9 p.m or sorry 10 p.m technically oh
where does she where does she it's they sent in a new
cleaner and i usually i oh did she throw away my cough chops
all of them
drops.
Oh, what?
Oh,
I just don't know.
I think she threw it away.
I'm like, I had like a bunch of cough drops.
I think she thought it was empty and then threw it out.
Oh, I didn't throw the trash bags, though.
Like, there's the trash bag in front of my door.
And, um, she didn't throw that out, at least.
Oh, really?
I think she did.
I think she, because, like, I had, like, I had, like, cough
drops, like, the aluminum foil containers, and I guess she
thought it was empty and threw it, put it in the trash,
because, like, I don't see it anywhere.
Oh, I don't even know if I have extra.
Wait, give me a sec.
Anyway, they sent in a new cleaner, and I was so tired,
because I only slept two hours, because...
Oh, I'm not talking about, guys, I'm too tired.
I'm too tired to be rage-baited right now.
I'm, I would say yesterday should not have counted.
I had a very important work call.
Yesterday should not have counted.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm, guys, I'm too tired to be rage-baited right now.
We'll be rage-baited tomorrow.
I'll talk about the leaderboards tomorrow.
I'll be rage baited tomorrow
Okay What was I gonna say What was gonna say?
Fuck, okay Wait, let me grab cough drops I thought I had
cough drops on my desk But I didn't realize The cleaners
threw it away Because it's nowhere I swear Oh, okay Okay,
I'm okay I'm okay I just oh, I just wanted cough drops.
Oh, she threw it away.
Oh, give me a sec.
I don't know if I'm anymore.
Thank you.
I have, I found a box.
I think the worst part is I have to dig through the trash
bag just to make sure she didn't throw it.
I don't, I, because like I had an when the first time I had
it, because like this cleaning service, you don't send the
same people.
Sometimes sometimes they send in a new person.
And, but like usually I would get like two of them.
They usually send the same two.
They'll like rotate between the two, but today it was a new
girl.
And so like one time when they sent another person in, they
threw some of, this was when dad was on the kidney
medication.
his syringe that i needed uh for his like to to you know
give him his medication to feed him his medication and stuff
um and then and they like threw it away i had to dig through
the trash bag to find it this was like a couple it was a
year ago um and so like usually i would give like
instructions on what they can and can't like like just to be
sure like oh don't throw away the trash bag so i can dig
through it if because sometimes i just i don't know
sometimes it's just like they just think see something
that's trash and this might not be trash and i've lost stuff
here too um so um and then they uh because uh i've had uh
i've had the cleaner here for a while um it was a reusable
uh it was a reusable syringe this is like last year so uh
incident i cured was that uh last year uh one of dad's
reusable syringes got thrown away and um obviously like
I don't have another one, so I had to dig through the trash
to find his syringe, because I was asking the cleaning
service to be like, hey, um, can you ask this cleaning lady
if she remember about throwing away a syringe or anything,
because that's my dog's, that's for my dog's medication.
And the thing is, it was like next to his medication, the
syringe was next to his medication, so I didn't think she
would throw it away.
But I guess she saw like, oh, a syringe, it must be like,
you know, one-time use, so then she threw it.
It's not like a needle syringe, syringe so it's not like a
needle or anything um so that made me super paranoid but and
so um i would like to supervise them or uh or like just give
them instructions being like um being like oh uh make sure
you don't uh if you throwing something away make sure you
ask me or uh or just like just throw stuff that's like like
paper track like not paper sorry like plastic trash stuff
like that like plastic uh like paper bags stuff that's fine
like just if you think you see something that might be trash
but you're not sure just put it away to the side and then
let me look at it so i've given those instructions before
and then they were sending the same two cleaning ladies for
me so they know like what i want and also i always tell them
don't touch the monitors that was another thing that's why
i'm like i'm not getting rage baited today i'm already rage
baited right now.
This morning was not my day already.
SK Demon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki, today's my birthday.
I like to ask for a selfish gift.
I'm currently doing lake tattoo with my Oshis.
I like to add you to design.
Can I have your blessing?
Of course, of course you can.
I'm going to make sure to post a photo.
I would love to see it.
But happy birthday to you, Demon.
Happy, sorry.
For some reason, I just forgot to say happy birthday.
It's because I don't want to give them royalties.
You guys know that, right?
That's why movies and TV shows.
Um, oh my god, it's more echoey now.
That, like, it's a lot, by the way, it's very, like, she
did, clearly did a great job.
It was just the fact that, like, she, um, she didn't get the
detailed instructions, um, that she did stuff I didn't like.
Um, anyway, Demon, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear demon.
Yeah, happy birthday.
All right.
So, um, shit, where was I at this story?
Um, so, um, I've had to clean my place for months.
Like, maybe four plus months.
Actually, I can check.
It's been a long time because I've been like, I don't want
to say depressed.
I've just, it's more so like, I've just been like more
stressed.
I've been stressed out and, um, really just like a lot of
work going on um and so i've been like a bit like not a bit
but like i've been sort of overworked and um i didn't really
want because i have to like clean do a pre-cleaning before
yeah i've been just been so busy and everything before the
cleaning lady comes in so i didn't want to deal with that i
just didn't have time to do pre-cleaning stuff um and like
because like I have to make sure like all like the trash and
stuff like that was taken out and everything and there's
like stuff on there was like stuff like just scattered
around and I want to make sure like you know I put those
things away when the cleaning lady comes in so like her job
is a little easier and also because I want to make sure like
things don't get put aside or like things don't get like
relocated and stuff so I just didn't want to deal with that
so I was finally able to like clean enough to the point
where I can have the clean lady finish the job And like, I
finally found the time that I could clean it up to for it to
finish the job.
And it's like, like, you know, the floors.
Because I don't do the floors.
I don't clean the floors or anything.
So it was dirty.
And I was just like, oh, fuck.
And the bathrooms too.
So I was like, I need to fix this up.
I need to call the cleaning service.
Because like, I can't delay this again.
Like, I can't delay it another way.
month so i was just like um when was the last time oh my god
wait no way okay all right um okay may may was the last wait
was it may yeah may was the last time the cleaning service
was here so obviously it has been a while and so i finally
you know found the time this week to actually pre-clean the
apartment so I could get the clean cleaning cleaner to come
in and just you know finish everything floors are very clean
tables are very clean like I was just like whoa it's like
night and day between like um uh between like what she did
with the place and what it was like before um but the thing
is I was so tired because like I said I'm um I only slept
for Well, May was last time.
Jennifer Marcipo, May, June, July.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's at the four months.
Yeah.
Well, usually they would come in monthly, but for some
reason, they forgot to like schedule the monthly cleaning.
And because they forgot to, they usually would just be like,
we're going to come here, blah, blah, blah.
Because in the past, I've had it monthly.
But around May, I think they like, because I was traveling a
lot.
So I was just like, oh, let's not do the monthly thing
anymore.
Because I'm traveling a lot.
I don't know like if I'll be there at home when uh when uh
when we're doing the monthly cleaning so then at that point
they like marked me off as for monthly cleaning um and then
at that point I was just like oh okay well when I well I'm
so busy right now I'll I'll remind I'll tell them remind
them about it when I have the time and then four months
passed I was like I should I should remind them yeah they
proposed it so I was just like maybe maybe i should remind
them yeah yeah uh anyway so uh when the cleaning coming came
in it was a new cleaning lady like i've never worked with
this one before uh with this one before uh and um i was so
fucking tired like i said i had two hours of sleep i was
just out of it um and i had to wake up an hour early because
i had to throw away the trash um because i did some pre like
i i cleaned up my fridge and stuff um and was cleaning out
like pick up some of the trash uh that was around and so i
woke up an hour early to take out the trash and everything
um and and it was not the smartest idea to stream six plus
hours of oni musha before the 10 a.m cleaning cleaning lady
coming in because i had two hours sleep and i was like legit
i I met up with her, took her to my apartment, and then I
was just like, I'm gonna go take a nap.
So just, just start with the bathroom first, and then finish
with the bedroom.
And that was all my instructions.
That was, that was all I said.
I was just like, bathroom, and then end with bedrooms.
So like I set up a timer.
I set up an alarm for myself, like two hours.
Cause I know like, you know, this is my first time at a
clean.
They came in and usually takes like three to four hours to
finish everything.
So I set my alarm to like two hours.
And then I woke up and then the clean lady knocked on my
door.
I was like, Oh, can I start with a bathroom now?
And I was just like, you know what?
You don't need to clean the bedroom.
Like, you know, it's all right.
You don't need to clean the bedroom because I wanted to
sleep a little longer.
I was like, I just wanted to sleep a little longer.
I was like, it's all right.
Maybe next month we'll do the bedroom.
Next.
We'll leave that for next month.
As long as the rest of the apartment is clean at that point,
I'm fine.
Like, we'll put that off for later.
well and I went back to sleep I set up another line for now
I was like I I need that one more hour I need that plus one
hour and I woke up like oh work I'm done I was like oh okay
and then you won't take look around and I I was like yeah no
problem and I looked it was so clean every she did an
amazing job and I got to my office and I see my monitors
pushed all the way back I have monitor arms by the way so I
saw my monitors pushed all the way back against the wall.
And I was like, oh, no.
I'm like, no, I do.
I forgot something.
I,
so for those who don't know, I feel like I know some other
people feel the same way.
But I'm super duper particular when it comes to like the
positioning of my monitors.
uh because i positioned it in a way that's like you know
that that's optimal for me and uh how i like it like you
know where my eye placement is and how everything looks like
because and if it's like even a little bit off like i get
like if it's like just a little bit off i it like it like
fucks with me i i like i know something's wrong like like i
know the same right you know like i'm thing is since she
pushed it all the way back, I have to redo the entire thing
on all three of my monitors.
And I know it's not correct, too.
Like I, I like put it back in what I think is, like maybe
it's like this, but I know I can feel it.
I can feel that this is not right.
And I can't do anything about it.
I'm like worried that like, I'm like, is my monitor too hot,
like too short now?
Like, is it like too low?
Like I'm not, it's just, oh, I don't know.
I, I was telling one of my friends and they're like, you
should do what pro players do.
They measure it out exactly to the dot of like what the
things are positioned, like how their monitor height is and
like the, and I'm like, that's, bro, like that's too much
work.
I might as well just, at that point I'm like, all right,
yes, this, I hate it.
I hate it when it's everything's off, but I'm like, not to,
but not enough that I would measure everything.
I was just like, that's, yeah, I'm just like, not enough
where I need to measure everything to the exact dot of where
everything is.
I, yeah, but it's just, oh, it just feels, everything feels
so wrong right now.
And I don't know.
I have a feeling my monitor is like a bit low.
And then like my left monitor feels like it's positioned
weird.
and I'm like I know this is not right I but I can't do
anything about it I just have to fucking get used to it for
like a week plus um it it bothers me it really I this is
like one of my fucking like uh what's it called my pet peeve
it's like one of my biggest pet peeve if like anyone touches
my monitor and I would spend like like I would spend like at
least an hour trying to fix it but it's I know it's I can
never get it the right way the same way as it was that I
liked it I could never get it to that point again.
It really grinds my gears.
Because I don't, none of this, none of this is right.
It all feels so wrong.
And it ruined, okay, I wouldn't say ruined my day, but like
I'm not happy.
It's like, it ruined my entire life.
i'll be depressed for the rest of the day but i just i'm not
happy i i just i'm tilted i'm so it just i'm just i'm uh i'm
just tilted now like i like she did an amazing job but this
one mistake threw everything off like i like i feel so bad
because like she did do it really good and everything else
but she touched my monitors and i know it's my fault because
i i was too tired to give her like the usual instructions of
like don't touch my mom that's it that's my instruction my
usual instructions i give to the cleaners don't touch my
monitors and i forgot to i forgot to give that instruction
no okay the first time a cleaning lady came in um i had like
um i got gifted like some pokemon cards and then uh she like
bent the pokemon card and i was so mad because like so i
have a shelf where i put all like the um like all the gifts
i got and like like all of them but at one point i put them
all out there like some of them and it was like a sylveon
card too like it was like uh one of my friends gifted me
like a sylveon card like a really nice much it cost or
anything i just knew it was really cute and then um when the
clean ladies came the one first clean lady came in and then
after that i told them never to touch that shelf because i
don't trust them i was like never touch the shelf again
because i and they were like moving stuff too they were
moving all the um all like the dokey stuff too and oh my
gosh why is dad barking and then so oh he's barking at me
why are you barking at me it's not food time is it food time
i'll give him a little bit yeah never touch the shelf my dad
remembers all right
all right let me see let me say how exactly it got it got
like bent a little i got really mad i'm not i don't think
mad i just wasn't happy about it can you see it i'm gonna
see i'm trying to see how i can see the crease because i
unbent it but it was like i don't know exactly
yeah i unbented i flattened it back yeah i flattened it back
and i don't even remember how she did it too i think she put
it underneath something so it like she put it underneath
something else i think and then that's how i got like
slightly bent and i was like so i was just like don't touch
that shelf again i was just like do not touch that shelf
after that just touch anything else or do not touch the
shelf or the monitors in the office that's it those were my
only instructions do not touch the shelf or the monitors
when you come to this office because like i just i don't
know i just don't i at that point i was like i already made
my you already made a mistake so I don't trust you anymore
to like not make the same mistake yeah you lost the shelf
privileges yeah amazing job touched my monitors two stars uh
Papa thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I
can't take any more chances anymore after that uh Kiago
thank you the super chat thank you thank you um but other
than that like I'm just mad at my monitors I'm just...
I...
I wish my mind...
I wish it feels the same.
Oh, it's all ruined.
Anyway, I'm really tired today.
I'm really tired today, but I'm gonna fucking power through.
We're gonna finally get the true ending of Armor Core.
I can't believe it's been three plus...
months it's been three plus months since we started this
game um we've gone through a lot together guys we've we we
have gone through a lot trying to uh get through uh get
through armor core and we're gonna make it to the end this
is it we're finally we're finally gonna get the true The
first time I've ever aimed for a true ending for you guys.
It has been quite a journey.
I don't even know how much I have.
Well, we're still...
We should be close.
We should be close to the true ending.
And, yeah, I'm looking forward to it.
It has been a while.
Since we...
Since we've like done, I actually don't even know.
This is the first time.
I want to say like, maybe like Hollow Knight true end.
Yeah.
Hollow Knight true ending was the first time.
Wait, did I get true ending for Hollow Knight?
I don't remember.
I got an ending in Hollow Knight.
Uh...
But I feel like Hollow Knight true ending is different than
like what I had to do for Armored Corde.
Because I didn't have to redo the game, you know?
I didn't have to like replay the game um it was more so of
me just like restart and then fighting them again yeah but I
felt like this is the first time I did like new game plus um
on stream for you guys because I usually never do new game
plus yeah I usually I usually just get an ending and then
we're good so yeah new this is the first time we've done new
game plus for any of the games long time so the very first
time i've done new game plus for you guys so it is a it is a
oh gosh my brain is so fried right now it's a checkpoint no
what's that word it is a moment in my career oh my god
there's a word for it oh my god what's the word it's not
checkpoint it is a it's a treat That thank you.
This is my my chat GPT right now at chat What is the word
where it's sort of like checkpoint and sort of like an
income?
That's what I've been doing lately.
I want to start reading again I feel like I've been really
brain rotted.
I can't tell if it's because I'm really tired or if it's the
mold that's giving me brain Fog or it's been my exposure to
mold Um, that's giving me brain fog or or if I just need I
need to start reading again or both, honestly.
I do think I have brain fog because I've been like, I've
been doing, I've been on Google being like, what is the word
for it, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Cause I couldn't remember the word and I Googled it out and
I was like, oh yeah, that word.
Perhaps both.
All of the above.
I feel that.
I feel like the, and I'm tired.
It's like I'm tired, my brain, the brain rot, cause I've
been watching shorts all the time lately.
Like, I've been watching videos any, like, I don't really
watch videos anymore.
I just watch shorts.
And then I also watch modern.
I've been trying to watch.
I'm watching Modern Family, too.
And also, my exposure to mold is causing the brain fog.
I think all of the above is fucking with me right now.
Yeah, I'm so fried right now.
So, so I feel like.
i feel like i need to start reading again and also that's
also why i was like i need a clean lady here because i don't
know there's mold right now i i was i was like paranoid i
was like oh god what if there's mold somewhere i don't i
need a clean lady here to like you start spraying like
anti-mold like i'm both killers in my in my apartment
because I don't know I got so paranoid I was just like oh no
it's been like four months since the cleaners here I got it
I need she needs to come back I don't know maybe there's
like moldy or something in my room right now yeah anyway
alright it is I'm her car alright let me let me just make
sure to save my sound settings for uh for from onimusha now
make sure that is saved before i do armor core let's see um
onimusha okay where's the armor core sound setting 7.3 All
right, I have to boot up the game.
Where the fuck is it?
All right, there you go.
Only Misha was really fun.
It's so hard.
It's such a hard game.
I really think it is one of the hardest souls like I've ever
played.
Because like, only Misha originally was not a souls like
game.
It's a fun game, but it's so fucking hard.
Like, all, because I can't, like, there's so many different
types of blocks and parries and dodges that's, um, um, that
correlates with specific, uh, moveset for each enemy.
So it's like, you can't, if they try that, you can't use,
you have to use dodge.
If they use, uh, if they do a, uh, sword attack, you have to
use parry, and it's just, ah, it's so frustrating.
Because I can't just use one type of block.
I have to use a variation.
Alright, one last sponsor for Goonbot.
One last sponsor for the road, guys.
Alright.
Do we have any last sponsor?
Our last sponsor for Goonbot.
One last job.
Gotta be a really special one.
I know there's like some that like we end up like because we
kept switching um decals or switching parts that there's
some parts that are not even there anymore so let me see
custom decal oh yeah here we go in use okay we have let the
fish fly buy more merch that's important oh there we go
one's a classic um oh yeah this one i think it was how do i
move the bot again i jk oh there you go and this one was
right here i remember this i remember this guy roku thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you one last job all
right I can't convert that.
Someone convert that.
Oh, okay, never mind.
NST, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank you.
There's a woman in my head that caused me.
Oh, my God, that is...
That might have been a hundred words.
I don't know.
Thank you for the magenta soup, NST, thank you, thank you.
All right, and then...
Let's see.
I think...
Oh, boobs.
There it is.
Okay, booze would always be at the core.
Yeah, it would be here.
Yeah, I'll put all our...
All our sponsors now, back on.
We're here.
Oops.
Nice.
Alright, do we have...
Do we have anyone higher than 6-7?
any other bidders and then I feel like the head is
definitely all wait actually since it's a new yeah it's a
new head so there isn't anymore um all right well who do we
what do you have let the fishes fly booze all right so I
think it's one I think it's what is sleep and little boom I
don't know if I can even put this you're right here wait I
like that what is really real and then we'll put one on the
left arm it's like a mom tattoo a little boom I'm a little
boom Fine, Perry, Palm, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Money, true.
Wait, that's a good one, actually.
One last sponsor.
Just money.
That has been your purpose, GoonBot.
You have served me well.
Real.
All right.
We have any other offers.
Any other sponsors?
opportunities for Goonbot.
This is our last your last chance your last chance to the
sponsor Goonbot.
The very last day you'll ever see Goonbot too.
The compilation this journey.
Money.
Any final takers before we go to Palm Perry pond going once
going twice solid the pond very pond for the sponsorship
space on good and buy and all in for money we have a money
symbol must be a money symbol right see there's that a bad
dragon I like how you went down
For him, but I don't think you know how auctions work for
him.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Bad dragon.
For him.
So, like, in an auction, you're supposed to go up, not down.
It's not like golf, bro.
It's not...
I'm sorry, man.
It's the opposite of golf rolls.
I was too slow.
You were so close.
All right, money.
But it looks like Shirley Undercutting works at an auction.
All right, it looks like the winner.
This is the award.
Oh, are we crowdfunding it now?
All right.
Who would like to...
Five Minutes Merge.
Ramona.
Thank you for the Aka.
Aka suit.
All right.
Well, I already have M in here.
Does anyone want to outbid Ramona Pilgrim?
Thank you for the Aka.
I'm sorry.
Pompeo.
I did.
I know I said sold.
But, like, I did slash JK at the end.
And you just didn't see it.
In my head.
I had slash JK.
There's also, in the TOS, there is sold, but with
exceptions.
And the exception is that if you get bid, outbid.
Oh, shit.
Ponpei Pot with another Akasupa with bigger money in all
caps.
Well, it looks like it's a TIE.
Will anyone like to... Okay, alright, alright.
The first person to break the tiebreaker wins the very last
sponsorship space on GoonBot.
The very...
The first person, doesn't matter who, it could be
crowdfunded.
You could be the first person to break...
to break the tiebreaker.
That is true.
Wait, actually, Pondery... Wait, we're talking...
Pondery...
My money has been maintained.
Wait, okay, sorry.
Sorry, I know I said the very...
Okay, look.
I did not think everything would be going...
Would come up at the same time.
I might have, like, did not think this through.
I might not have thought this through, guys.
I...
Now it's a poor way.
Alright.
I'm Doug.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bye, Miss Murasamba.
I can't do all this map.
Money has been the theme.
Maintain the theme.
Pond.
Thank you for the magenta super chat.
Thank you.
Quill.
Medi's fan club cannot fund this man.
Lair bear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Voting for president.
money many thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
all right guys just like in real life money always wins in
the end
cinema absolute cinema for me all right how to change the
colors here
I'm trying for how to change colors.
It's been a while.
I'm just gonna... You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm just gonna discard it.
In the end.
Just like the world...
Money shall always win.
Exactly gaming.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're just a reflection of what life gave us.
Alright.
I...
I don't remember how to change the colors of...
Money.
We have a bunch of adds here.
Maybe extra gold.
I will use stickers.
We'll put it on green.
I feel like it's appropriate for it to be green.
Money.
In all caps, too.
Okay.
Oh, nope.
Do not discard it.
just like the real world money always wins in the end our
final sponsor I feel like those people who like you know
when they are on the doing posters and stuff they do it to
do the text too big and if the start slowly shrinking it
because they did not account for this the width of the
document
money and then dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign there's a
dollar sign okay and then dollar sign dollar sign dollar
sign get
a little fancy here
there we go money
nice all right where should we put this one last job goon by
one last job like the maybe the core on
the heart the hearts here right I keep forgetting the hearts
on the left or right
all right then we'll add another one too We're at it on the
left arm.
Like a mom tattoo.
But it's a money tattoo.
Money!
It's beautiful.
Oh my god.
It's just there.
Money!
I like how it's just there.
Put it in the back too.
It's like a money tramp stamp.
It's beautiful
Money Oh, and we should put it We should actually put it on
the tramp stamp though
Oh, shit Wait, it'll go perfect here
Make sure you get your money's worth Guys I'm making sure
You're getting your money's worth
Yeah Yeah Did I put it under?
Oh, oh, wait, is that like where?
No, that's not.
Oh, wait, it is!
I show you my money.
Please respond.
I showed you my money.
There we go.
And that's good.
Anywhere else I could put it in.
I could put it on the side as well.
No, let's see Oh,
I could put in the back.
Oh Put it on the gun.
Oh, that's true.
It's like my money shot The way I can't though.
I don't think the gun.
Yeah, the guns don't have decals.
I'm pretty sure Yeah, guns don't have decals All right, it's
beautiful.
He's so beautiful my little money tattoo it's like i love
money versus if i love mom okay what do we do for this we've
done both of these before right i do not remember all these
missions have been blurring together for me but thank you
again thank you again to my sponsors for sponsoring my gun
bot our last sponsor for today our last sponsor for the
stream for the series too huge shout out to perry for being
the Kickstarter of the money sponsor and all the investors
that he got in the end to take it to the end to out bid
everybody it was new game plus plus we are at we're trying
to get the second ending new missions a bottom on this one
because I don't know if I've done both already or there's
new ones is it this Yeah, all the, yeah, shout out to all
the Venture Capitalists for crowdfunding the money, uh, the
money ad space.
Yeah, we're at true ending.
This is true ending, guys.
So is it this one?
Okay, so I'd be sure.
I've done both.
Also, I feel like there, I, what?
I didn't press, oh, okay.
I guess that's it.
Also, like, I don't know if it's a placebo effect, but, um,
my keyboard feels like weird.
I don't know, like, if she's, like, touching my keyboard or
something, or I'm just, like, cranky from, um, from the
monitors being shifted, because, like, my keyboard feels
like, like, it's a wooden keyboard, so it's supposed to be,
like, fast keys, but it feels like Like harder to press
down, but I don't know if it's just a placebo effect for me
right now Or I'm just tired my hands have no strength like
I don't know Yeah, it's supposed to have very fast response
time, but it doesn't feel very fast So I'm like maybe or
maybe I'm just so tired that I have weak hand strength right
now
I'm so weak you to obliterate them.
It feels so weak right now.
Corporate gains.
Raven, I await your favorable response.
Is this my eye?
No, this is my Wooting 2 keyboard.
I'm just gotta be sure.
Is this Wooting 2?
Yeah, version 2.
Alright, here we go.
I'm not using my gamer mouse pad right now because I um, I
removed all my mouse desks.
I'm doing my Desk mat, my mouse pad.
Just because I was getting that clean.
So I'm just using my desk right now as a...
As I guess, like, for my mouse.
Because it's smooth enough that it'll work.
I'm playing Armor Core.
I'm not, like, playing, like, something super intense
competitively.
Alright.
That's easy.
Boom!
Wait, what?
Where is he?
I was like, bro, he dodged?
It's not loud, that's illegal.
Why are you dodging?
Why are you scared of me?
Oh shit.
Alright, let's get these guys out of the way.
I actually do not have to kill any of them.
I'm just doing it for fun at this point.
Actually, I should speedrun this though.
yeah how mobile oh shit wait they're real people oh they
actually gave you a budget oh shit oh shit I didn't realize
they're real they actually gave him a budget
They actually cared about your lives!
For a second there.
Please, I'm so...
I'm tired.
Said still!
I'm EP!
I can't believe they actually gave you a budget!
Whoops.
Go to three.
Attending feet Yeah, they got the healthy Easy Oh, that was
fast.
That's it?
You that you lasted like five seconds You were you were
easier than the fucking Taddy sniper bros You fight like a
bird in flight than the twins You may yet fly higher
To chase the freedom.
We never knew.
Imagine putting your tax dollars in this mecha just to get
destroyed in 10 seconds.
That's where your tax money went to.
See, that's why you should sponsor Goonbot.
Gotta sponsor the independent contractors.
Look at what company money got you.
Look at what the...
It's like getting a public defendant.
Well, but I doubt the voices have gone away.
At any rate, whatever the voices are, it doesn't seem to be
doing any harm for now.
I was asking about you, Walter.
Yeah, are you okay, Walter?
Okay.
Bigger things.
The coral.
You better find it.
Turns out, our friends' fears were warranted.
Don't spend too long dealing with the PCA, Walter.
Clock's ticking.
Tick tock.
All right.
God, he's so beautiful.
I love his money tattoo.
Raven.
Yes, my wife?
About what?
Rubicon scorched skies and chased the freedom we never knew.
The others are so used to fighting and shouting slogans that
they've given up sinking.
But Flatwell, he's exploring a potential for something new.
It's okay, I've played these games before.
Everything will be fine, my beautiful wife.
We'll be together forever for the third time.
It's like keep rewind.
It's like the Madoka effect.
I keep rewinding so we can always spend so I can fix the
timeline where we can be together forever.
But in the end, it's a canon event.
We could find some clues here.
I heard a Numanoka movie was fucking terrible.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna pretend there was never a Numanoka movie.
It makes me so sad.
It makes me so...
Oh, go back?
Why?
Wait, why go back?
Bottom mission, this one?
If I do this one, does it just skip all of these missions?
Apparently, people were saying, like, it's the worst movie
they've ever made in the Madoka franchise.
I don't know, because I didn't spoil, I don't really know,
like, what's going on with it.
But people were like, do not watch it.
Destroy enemy craft.
Destroy the planetary closure administration special force
craft.
Is that, is this the mission I should be doing?
This request comes from the Rubicon Liberation Front.
let's see what it says it's not that one oh is it this one
six two one we've also got a corporate job check the
briefing oh before the mission which one I guess You can't
be a high mind You're like No, not that one The one above it
There's no new missions Guys, I need you guys to become A
high mind Start Start linking up Sorry
Alright, we're gonna do the floating city first I feel like
I've done this one before.
I don't need to listen to briefing.
Oh, it's this one.
God, I hate this one.
I hate this mission.
So it's like, not me.
The floating city.
I hate this one.
Oh, my God.
Is this where...
Someone said there's new content in this one.
She's coming, isn't she?
She's coming.
Isn't she?
she?
Every time someone says there's new content, she's here,
isn't she?
She's right behind me, right?
Right now.
All
right.
I already forgot what I was talking about before I got
distracted by the hive mind.
What was I talking about before I got distracted by the hive
mind?
Oh my God, these guys.
Oh my God!
Oh, Madoka.
Yeah.
Apparently it's like really poorly written or something.
And people were like, do not watch this movie.
Which makes me so sad because I've been waiting for like the
sequel for them.
The next installment for so long.
Just to find out it's, like, really poorly written,
apparently.
But I'm lost.
Oh, it's here.
Being Magica has always been suffering, guys.
It's this way.
Yeah, I have no idea what makes it bad.
It's just people, all, like, the Magica fans are, like, do
not watch it.
It's not worth your time.
Oh No, oh, it's here
Is she follow me
Oh my god, I said this before I said this that's exactly
I've said this before The face is a deja vu this is no It's
a deja vu.
Who's hitting me?
There we go.
We've been here before.
The data we found helps to identify where the last ECM
devices.
Where is it?
Okay, it's this way.
Let's check it out.
It's been a long time since we've been on a mission
together.
Alright, we're almost there.
The control device isn't going anywhere.
all right whoops i went too fast
okay so this is where the i'm gonna hide under here
registration number rb23 call signer we gotta go find the
little bots that would help us you have been followed
contact is imminent here he comes hauston island coming
there he is what this place will be your grave um wait what
what the fuck are you you okay at least it's not the other
Raven I mean that's fine he
healed okay oh my he's so fast he's actually so fast
oh yes you have a wife in your head too we should be best
friends where did he go oh my god same same voice we should
be best friends how much why are we fighting same voice one
two three four odd Clear some more.
Thank you, a super chat.
I'm not crazy.
We're both perfectly normal.
He's just done a little bit too many.
He's just done, like, one drug, guys.
You skipped the dialogue?
I was dying!
I decided he killed...
I let him finish monologuing, and I die.
Guys, I can't...
If he kissed my logging, I'd be dead.
His wife left him.
I had no more heals.
Monologue or death?
Tough choice.
No, no.
I'm sorry, I did not respect the monologue rule.
See, look, my wife told me.
My wife is giving me my exposition.
It's fine.
Coral release.
As always, she whispered to me from the inside.
She tells me that she has found something in journals.
such a thing is truly possible then perhaps i can join her
on the other side oh i guess he's not crazy guys just
because we both have voices in our head doesn't mean we're
crazy he really did experience contact like you and i
release to free the core he really wanted me to listen to
his monologue he should have given me a cut scene the
potential for symbiosis symbiosis i mean we can be
all right now i can do the other missions i want to give you
a thumbs up i see no way you deal with them just now i fear
for the safety of mine dreda thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you all right let me i should need water
real quick i'll be right back me run out of water i'd be
right back guys
all right we're back we're back we're back why what do you
mean by we doky me and my wife voice in my head.
Of course.
What else?
Who else would I be talking about?
Shading on.
Medi.
NSD is solid.
Jade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm ready.
It's almost time, Raven.
Let's head over.
Hopefully the dozers won't be too dosed up on call to make
an appearance.
Who else would I be talking about?
Oh, this is taking a long time to load.
what am I loading oh no it's okay it's here I know how to do
this I've done this before I won't I won't fuck around like
last time and the time before that oh Oh, whoops.
Starting now.
They're not kill all of them?
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's all.
It's fine.
They're not taking damage yet.
They don't start taking damage until the waves commences.
All right, starting now.
I won't fuck around.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
How did it all take damage?
How did this happen?
They didn't show the HP!
Oh my god.
If I knew, I might have been a little faster.
Maybe.
Keep the fireworks safe.
We're coming from the front left side.
Intercept Raven.
This is my fuck!
Already fucked around and found out.
Gotta just knife him.
I just thought...
I meant shoot him.
Okay, where's the others?
It sure counted in the countdown, not gonna lie.
Alright, all these guys are far, far.
We got the fire.
Is anyone else?
Okay, I see them.
Go as fast as I can in my wheelchair.
Where?
Oh shit above me.
No, I can't fly!
No, don't!
Don't send them down!
Maybe I can...
Okay, yes, okay, I can knife them.
I can knife them.
No!
Okay, it's fine.
He'll be sent three.
Not even worried at all.
Alright, this way.
So you gotta get these guys out early.
Bridge?
Oh, fuck, it's the big guys.
spicy or not what how did it breach the lines oh my god
there you go i should kill all of them
that's five get nice anymore but two more minutes is where
things get more exciting a little bit spicy chatty's almost
ready Don't fill us now, Taurus.
Chattie, why can't you work faster?
Why didn't you make food, Chatties?
We got more toy box mechs.
Don't let any through.
Left shoulder ammunition at fifth-light shoulder ammunition
at 15%.
All right, it's five.
All right.
Maybe he's off a little tourist.
There won't be anyone left to see the fireworks.
All right.
Holy shit, he's 1 HP.
How did he take so much damage?
Nobody should have touched him.
Any more?
This way.
Oh, I thought I hit those.
Is there anyone behind me?
Okay, I was worried.
I was a little paranoid.
Alright, nice.
I will go.
good to go is that oh fuck okay left side is guy he's not
making it he is absolutely absolutely not making it oh no
there you go all right
that's the stuff thanks for the pre-show tourist
They all live!
All done.
Job done.
Boy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You need a serious idea to overpower them who can't finish
his monologue before defeating the hero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At that point, he just gave up, like...
That guy is Mega Man.
What's the point?
You know, when you have everything?
Well, most of us is good enough for me.
challenge what's the point
so beautiful make a wish darling make a wish it's okay
nobody lives there so we didn't kill anyone
so pretty isn't mass destruction just beautiful babe
with the fireworks show the chief loved working with you so
don't be a stranger that's all i had to say i think chatty
the songs you pay me will be best friends i want to be sure
we completed all of them yeah we did there's still two more
left in there all right what's cheapest i assume the
cheapest is the easiest so i'll do that What do you mean?
Cursed.
I'm Camo.
621.
We've also got a corporate job.
Check the briefing.
If he's best boy, why did he die?
Special forces would be faster.
Liberation front took action.
Oh, it's this one.
Okay, eliminate the special forces.
I swear to God, if you lie, of me Yoshi.
I swear to God.
If I see this, if I click this mission and then I remember
what this is, I swear to God.
The
cheaper one is what I need for the true ending.
Is that true?
I don't want to get white guy.
Can anyone vouch for the white gibbous man?
Who would want to vouch the white gibbous man?
Or is he one guy in me?
It is.
not true well well I hate to break it to you and destroy
everything you know about armor core but apparently you're
the choice does not matter everything you know about armor
core was a lie how does it feel how it works for the ending
NSD, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
White Gibbous, man, how does it feel?
Everything you knew about this game was a lie.
I'm chatted.
He's like, what do you mean, both mattered?
You mean all this time, all this time, I never had to
choose.
I could pick whatever I wanted.
And...
Oh my god.
Oh my god Say something.
Did he die?
He's like, my purpose is gone.
He's just like, he has disappeared into the void.
He actually evaporated.
The enforcement squad is just nicer, I guess.
Broken I am.
He's like, what is my purpose now?
I'm just a shell.
of a human knowing that everything I knew didn't matter.
Shattered by the truth.
He just fucking got sucked into the void.
Alright, which is easier?
The special force is just one boss?
Alright, we'll do that.
Since the liberation front are hoping their rivals will wear
each other down.
They must be desperate to avoid confrontation.
girl he wanted to continue the cycle not me though i i broke
the cycle congratulations
he's just trying to continue the cycle oh it's this guy this
this fucker all
right this guy is definitely easier i've got I shoot him in
the face.
I don't know.
His defense is, like, not the best defense.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, I'm freaking did not mean that.
I'm sorry.
But he's like, what did you say?
Oh, my God.
I'm face-sinking that just because I can't.
There you go.
I mean, it's just him.
So it's like, oh, my God.
mind as long as he looks at me it should be fine
Wow damn see I told you as long as he looks at me it should
be fine I looked very much over I feel like you should put a
shield in front of that not gonna a lot yeah you might be on
a wheelchair but I'm the better wheelchair user I could do a
sick willy wheel you with this wheelchair on wheelchair
violence see
it's not a hate crime we're both we're both around the
wheelchair guys we're on equal grounds.
You again.
I'm a busy man.
Far too busy for the likes of you.
So I hear.
Must be a tough time to be the Vesper's deputy commander.
Get to the point.
The plan to raid the PCA.
You're going to need more pawns on the board.
We're on equal chairs.
Exactly.
Of course.
The bigger the wheelchair, the bigger the bomb.
Perfect.
One more thing.
Show my hound some respect.
The hardest to control.
All right.
Next mission.
Next job.
Oh, one message.
It's a new one.
The new one.
It's pretty easy.
The valuable asset.
Mean?
I'm MVP.
Really?
and the pca no we need to stand on our own two feet that's
how we'll win
raven just so you know it looks like some unknown craft data
has been added to the integration program why don't we go
take a peek either way oh new data oh last oh no not the the
last one.
Oh, they're edging these data's now.
It's one by one.
They're going to have promising count to serve as a project
secondary factor.
That man's greatly... Wait.
That's me.
Wait.
That's Walter.
How does she have Walter's data?
Wait a minute.
That's Walter's data.
She knows.
Raven, this data was kept secret by online.
Why though?
Main system, activating combat mode.
Every time Luke, she knows.
Oh my god, you bitch.
Oh, he's just as annoying to fight even in AI for him.
That's fine.
It's just I can't get close enough to pile bunker.
What did he do to me?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what he does to me as long as he's dead
anyway.
Yeah.
I wonder who would that be.
Shielding yourself doesn't fucking shield from a point blank
big boom.
Alright, nice.
Alright, goodbye.
Bye.
That machine.
They clearly used coral technology.
But what connection does it have to the fires of Ibis?
It's red?
You're a coral.
You should recognize it.
It's red.
Wait, true?
Here's the briefing from my CEO Who came up with the plan
Hey, Rusty This is V2 Snail I shall brief you on the
operation You will be under my direct authority Consider it
a rare privilege That's my Buddy Yeah Yeah, we have
nicknames for each other yes yeah i call my husband buddy
that's how we serve my very good friend v4 rusty will be
dispatched to handle the hall of base this objective will be
to disable their network and prevent support from pc elite
squads raven during this time you must destroy all Oh, it's
these.
Okay.
I know what briefing this is.
I saw giant ships and I was like, yep.
Between wife or buddy?
Um, God gave us two hands for a reason.
It's called husband and wife.
Main system, activating combat mode.
Uh, this one's easy.
easy oh wait the big worms coming here yeah sharing all base
personnel commencing threat evaluation people can't do a
wheel they're just weak come on standby near harlov buddy
patch me in i'll gauge the situation on your end before i
jump in i've
taken out the relay mask whoa in front of everybody used to
call me buddy in front of in front of everyone like that
whoa Oh, PDA.
Oh my gosh, I'm rushing, Rusty.
Just like that.
Oh, I thought that wasn't bad.
Looks like you're doing just fine, buddy.
I'm keeping them busy, but they're working fast.
Where am I?
Holy shit, I was like slammed into that.
I'm almost there.
My wife and my husband.
I'm just gonna get rid of that guy.
Guess not.
I'll get rid of him on the ship.
It just exploded with the ship at least.
Bad news.
PCA's external comms are back online.
Alright.
They've got warships heading your way.
What are they?
I'm ready.
I'm ready for them.
Give me your best shot.
Oh, it's over there.
All the way up here?
So far.
What?
Oh, is this a resupply?
Yeah, it's a resupply.
Didn't need it.
I'm just gonna use it anywhere.
To waste my company's money.
It snails money, so it's fine.
Get this guy out of here.
Get this P-shooter out of my lobby.
Code 5.
Target for termination approaching.
Handle it.
The main squad will be here soon.
Oh my god.
How dare you use cover, you pussy?
That's them sniping you.
Alright.
I...
Look.
That should hit him eventually, right?
I'm on a wheelchair!
This is discrimination!
This is workplace harassment.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh my, this is actually workplace harassment.
All right, where is he?
Oh, they're all right there.
There's not wheelchair accessible.
Alright, I will be up point length.
Can I make it?
I do.
I should.
Oh, shit.
I'm too fast.
Too fast.
Too fast!
Okay, nice.
At least this one's, like, more to the ground.
Oh, no.
Please tell me I make it.
They gotta make it Are not killing How did you oh my god my
auto it goes anywhere?
But the sentry All right,
we're gonna skip that Send me what you've got on the target
Remains for some response It's just save mode save us Okay
Oh fuck
Nice.
Chop.
All right, your turn, Rusty.
It's all right, Rusty.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Kitten.
Daddy's here.
Just heal.
Just damage boost me.
And I'll protect you, Kitten.
Just hop in my backpack.
Oh, worm tab.
If I'm up here, it shouldn't hurt me.
The worm can't hurt me if I'm up here.
There he is.
Worm.
Is that the Laskin Boer?
There he is.
Don't worry, I'm not.
high ground what what is that thing so weird
look at him again you can't get me i'm on high ground i
can't get a read on it this is bad oh my god no my other
high ground All my other high ground words are so far high
ground Wait, wait, wait, wait It's okay, I see it I see
another high ground You can't get me up there Fuck your high
ground
Wait, something's wrong It's
changing its behavioral pattern Answering to a greater
imperative And what it calls for you What do they say?
High crowd turned out to be higher.
The worm beckons.
Looks like the PCA has helped itself to the Institute's
relics.
Even the worm has a wife?
Look, if the worm can have a wife, you can too, guys.
If the worm can get game, you guys can also get game.
Be like the worm.
Here's the situation, 621.
After the PCA sicked that Institute weapon on us, Archibus
and Balaam have moved to cooperate.
There's hope for all of us.
IA-02, aka Ice Worm.
It's a sea weapon.
An autonomous deterrent created to protect the coral.
if we don't take it out no one's going to reach the
convergence
we'll have a tough fight ahead of us everyone's getting
involved
six to one don't forget we've got a job to do on rubicon i
didn't bring you all the way to this game is you stealing
rusty thunder and bullying iguanas or see as a buddy says
cool and iguanas deserve it Thank you.
We've received your request.
And it's about coral release.
The message is highly encrypted with top-level security and
designed not to leave a trace.
In other words, Almind doesn't want Walter to know about
this.
I feel like if she knows what's going on, why is she still
so bad at encrypting?
Aya has hacked every single one.
one of them.
I feel like...
I feel like this one should be better encrypting stuff.
She would have upgraded her security at that point.
I got something that might interest you.
Sent you a briefing.
Sorry to impose on you, Raven, but I just sent you an urgent
request.
I wish we could deal with this in a row.
But we've got no choice but to count on you.
Take a look and see what you think.
You must have a lot of money if you think you can count on
me.
Alright, what's just a new one?
This one, right?
Oh, wait, no, not this one.
Wait, actually.
Which one is the new one?
The coral expert denial, right?
Yeah.
This one I assume is the one with Aria.
export denial is new me mission if i were more transparent
are you fucking kidding me before export oh my god it's an
escort mission um all right oh wait no it's not an escort
mission it's like i have to it's a time technically a time
mission registration number rb23 augmented human c4 621
raven all mind has identified you as a asset to the release
project accordingly we would like to assign you the
following mission yeah following the attack on watchpoint
Delta Rubicon has experienced a series of coral upsurges
okay of these the corporations have seized 1.6% of the
estimated total volume well technically it's time because
they're like escaping analyze this coral at their research
bases and have initiated an We cannot allow the corporations
to interfere with the project.
Attack the Yorkin refueling base and destroy as many
corporate transports as possible.
They're like, can't attack with the, make sure to sacrifice
the coral that will be lost upon destruction of the
transports.
It's fine.
They're like fishes, right?
They can just make more.
In order to achieve release, we must try to have the full
potential of the coral density effect.
This, as such, this meiosis slash mitosis.
has been orphaned from the main population whoa fuck orphans
am i right damn all mine
you have no home they're orphans we must destroy them their
lives do not matter all mind reiterates its gratitude We
must burn down that orphanage.
All mine probably.
Take off the pile.
What?
Oops.
Don't worry.
I'll chop the helicopter.
I can chop a helicopter, guys.
and we'll dispose of any transports that escape to combat
zone.
What the fuck just happened?
They're not doing very good job at that.
I will say they're not doing a very good job at defending.
We have detected more transports attempting lift-off.
I got you.
I should explode both.
Wait.
Transport detected below the cliff.
Investigate immediately.
Let me do.
Where's below the cliff?
Oh, it's here.
Yeah, I just ignored all of them.
Little pea shooter guns don't do much
All right, oh, that's a lot of helicopters Choppy choppy
Don't worry, I got this
Oh, come on I should hit.
Ha ha!
Get sniped!
Big boom.
You guys started the big boom.
Nobody ever believes in the big boom.
Nothing like a sniper bazooka.
All right.
We're almost here.
Target's acquired.
Multiple transports attempting breakthrough.
Boom.
Is that it?
Pathetic.
Raven, use the vertical catapults to move between the upper
and lower areas.
Okay, that was scary.
I don't need a move!
I'll lead my shot.
Oh shit.
All right.
There you go Told you Just lead the shot Oh my god, there's
more
All right, my last one All right, that should be out of them
Do more Those are chocolate you and the guys are annoying me
you have to lose transport overhead you do oh shit
no oh no oh no oh down
there you go there you go there you go there you go oh
no i'm running out guys it's It's bad, I'm running out of
juice now.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, this is so bad!
I got too overconfident!
A transport, a second transport.
No!
They're so fast!
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
oh you are testing this is bad it's actually pretty bad now
I'm gonna fucked up a little bit guys oh this is so bad I I
fucked around and played I fucked around and found out I
actually fucked around and found out
No No
Just hit one No, no
I fucked around and found out I was trolling too hard I
trolled too hard
I was like, I need the jump patch.
It's for babies.
I thought I was so cool.
I thought I...
They want the core to defend the transport.
I thought I was so cool.
We have detected more transports attempting liftoff.
It seems you're finished here.
I am finished here.
Transport detected below the cliff.
Investigate immediately.
I don't need to.
My wheels, it's not my fault that they're wheelchair and
that they're not wheelchair accessible.
they should be accommodating me not the other way around
oh my god i don't know why i didn't think that was a real
helicopter the one in front of me was i was like that's not
real all right we're good
In fact, they should be fine for discriminating against
people who are disabled.
Okay.
Here you go.
Multiple transports attempting breakthrough.
Damn it.
We've been spotted.
I need to get rid of this guy.
This guy is annoying.
Here you go.
Oh, where is the vertical catapult?
Okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
We'll get the catapult.
Not again!
Use that AC down.
Don't let it get up there.
Supporting.
Speed up those transports.
Okay.
There we go.
What the?
Oh, God.
Oh, God, what do you mean I didn't hit?
There you go.
What are you doing?
You got to lose transport overhead.
What?
Where?
Okay.
Oh.
There you go.
Oh, God, yeah.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I see, are you?
Oh, I'm fucking moving as fast as I can!
How did I just...
Oh my god, that actually stressed me up.
My god's right with me.
Demunition at 50%.
Oh!
Is that the last of them?
It's not.
I know it's not.
I know you're fucking with me.
Dispose of them.
Oh, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Keep going, keep going.
It's alright!
This will please us to lose the orphaned coral.
But when the release project succeeds, their sacrifice will
be rewarded.
The sacrifice I'm willing to take!
Oh my god, I don't like that.
They pause this after too.
Oh, my God.
I made it.
I hit it.
I hit those.
I hit.
Look at that.
You guys did not believe in big boom.
You did not believe in the power of wheelchairs.
That's little Elvis of you.
Not gonna lie.
You think just because I'm in a wheelchair, I can't complete
a job that walking people can.
can't do a better like that's as good as a job as someone
that can walk just because i'm in a wheelchair wow that says
a lot about you than me
no new messages yes
there's something that troubles me about all mind i've been
looking for information on Yeah, because she's a mercenary.
She's...
Why don't you sat up and say that?
That's right.
Not handicapped.
Handicapable.
Maybe she's off the grid.
I mean, to be fair, her mercenary name is Kate Merson.
Like...
Alright, let's see.
Doing these don't matter, so just do whatever.
I'll cut to the chase Thank you to the super chat Thank you
Doki and Game with melee focus Where's my ranged weapon Doki
and a mecca with gun games I'll chop the helicopter Quail,
thank you for this Oh, this slow slow quick guy How Quail,
thank you for the super chat Thank you How about walking?
Why don't you stand?
I'm gonna say it to my face No one's gonna miss Brute And we
all
All right, here we go.
All right, let's just go straight in.
Remember last time, I'm going to destroy the guy.
On his brute.
Yeah, I worry about the traps.
You're a friend of Carla's.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, okay.
Whoops.
Here's to new beginnings.
By all means, be my guest.
See what I mean, tourist.
We need to- I'm gonna drop down next.
Uh, here.
Oh, it's trap time, trap time.
Make sure you keep clear of the laser sensors.
You're set to activate the enemy machines.
A new friend from afar.
Whoa, whoa!
All right, we're fine.
All right.
Should be where he is?
Is this the field?
No, he's...
He's right below me.
Oh.
Do I make it?
I don't make it.
I remember.
I do not make it.
I...
Alright, let's get rid of these.
I hate to see my babies get scrapped.
Oh, it's fine.
I can take a couple of damage.
Okay, not that much, though.
Chill, chill.
Chill!
Oh my gosh, what the fuck?
He lives those?
Alright, where's the other guy?
Oh,
wow!
I did not see the big guy in front of me!
Alright, now it's just...
Now it's just time to deal with the traps here.
It's fine.
Alright, we're safe.
Right here.
Dreading the needle.
Oh?
I'll get rid of this one.
Is that not where he is?
Alright, he should be here soon.
Alright, this is where he is.
The guy's a rat.
This won't be smooth sailing.
One repair kit remaining.
Alright.
You slowly fall down.
The target AC must be nearby.
Yeah I'm just gonna be down here
Oh my god, I forgot it's oh My god cats that forgot up a
high cat fucking see Where is he
Thank God you're a good thing.
Oh my god, wait with the hit in me with it I hit you or did
you hit me?
I hate fighting this guy.
There you go.
Oh my god.
He's gonna do nothing for you.
There you go.
One more hit.
You're one hit.
Yeah!
That easy.
GG easy.
Don't quit your day job.
good all right tourist i'll see you by retreat yeah maybe
you're not cut out maybe you're not cut out for this yeah it
was quick quick quick quick not slow quick quick one
new message
this is chatty stick r-a-d no chatty thanks for putting down
brute the chief's already in the workshop tweaking the rail
cannon and i've never seen her happier to be at work that is
all later tourist bye thanks for the update chatty all right
is it it's not worm time i think after this is worm time
yeah boom or die
I'm loyal.
We have a mission we'd like you to take on.
The objective is to defend the Gallia Dam complex in the
Belyus region.
Archibus has been stepping up pressure on the Rubiconians
while fighting the PCA.
Alright, destroy two top ranking independent.
Alright, he's two again.
Alright, after this.
after this then we get worm time
all right kill these two kill them again let's get started
Raven which one do I have here what do they say out of the
tab his reputation for finesse is such that he's advertised
as the ideal mercenary
by chartreuse an aggressive bulldozer with unrivaled
firepower they're so good why did it die to me at least
three times did we kill again
what do i i'll kill the left side left side was more
successful
you must be free not an aim i expected to see attached to a
hostile ac We know our priorities, Chartreuse.
Let me deal with this.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Oh, fuck.
I haven't seen anything like this since.
Together, Chartreuse.
How did I miss?
Oh, I did miss.
JK.
I beat it.
Pull your head out of your ass and withdraw.
AC Astro Crown destroyed
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I spammed Z!
Oh my god, I got sunlocked.
I got sunlocked!
That bitch, I'll kill you first.
I'll kill you first.
Oh my god, how dare you?
I sunlocked you.
You!
God, I'm gonna kill your boyfriend last.
I'm gonna make you, I'm gonna watch you.
I'm gonna make your boyfriend watch you die.
Knowing that he couldn't save you.
Don't take care of the objective king.
I'll clip this one's wings.
Oh wait, I forgot.
Oh, I forgot why I don't kill her first.
She just fucking floats like a coward.
And your boyfriend didn't even get to watch you die.
He couldn't see your final moments.
That's right.
Till death do you part.
Don't worry.
I'll send your boyfriend over to hell too.
You'll see him soon.
Or I'll make him roam purgatory.
In fact, I hope he doesn't even go to the other side.
I hope he rose purgatory forever.
And then you two will never get to see each other again.
No, what?
What?
The Raven...
She comes back!
Do you read me, Raven?
Your imposter must be an impressive pilot.
I thought I thought she shows up at another oh my god you
again it's new game plus plus be original augmented human c4
6-2-1 oh come on
You're late.
The imposter already got your truth.
We can't take chances.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Oh, she kicks me out.
Oh,
my God.
She's stunned me.
What?
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you identity
theft is not a joke not face too okay okay okay okay now
that i know i thought raven will show up at a different
mission because i already killed her in this one okay i'll
kill the boyfriend first the girlfriend is actually harder
when she has when she's on low ground she doesn't fly him as
much here.
Which makes it a lot easier for me.
Why can't I Sorin!
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, I hate you.
it's so hard okay i know some people are like why is she
never using auto lock but if you ever use mouse and keyboard
auto lock it doesn't work that way it always uh for those
who've never used mouse and keyboard auto lock it always
very easily unlocks themselves so it's very it's it's it's
it's the tilty part but i'm too committed It's too late!
Your imposter must be an impressive pilot to take on the two
of them at once.
That's why we don't...
It's too late!
This is a Bed-Eyed Lion!
I have to live with it now!
Okay,
there we go.
This is the life I live!
We'll take it from here, Shatruth.
I've accepted my fate.
I've got this far.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
It's okay.
I've been in her before.
I've stolen her identity multiple times, Doki.
I can do it again.
I can steal her identity again.
You must be Raven.
Am I expected to see attached to a hostile AC?
You know what priorities, Shartreus?
Let me deal with this.
Give me a break.
Oh my god.
King!
Pull your head out of your ass and withdraw AC astro crown
Oh my god, this is a crisis You're just a gen four you
belong in a museum not the AC Oh Come on, oh no Oh, please
get down Get down mr.
Poison dude Okay all right all right we got okay we killed
it before before raven came in all right here you go oh you
read me raven your imposter must be an augmented human c4
621 we're not here to take back the raven day all right
however here we go again we will see if you could do it
justice
Wait, that's not my way.
I don't think this is a coincidence.
Damn.
AP at 50%.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Oh my god.
Fucking course you.
We're in the air.
Bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch,
bitch, bitch.
Bitch, bitch.
There we go.
That's right.
You can still what?
Huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm better.
I'm you, but better.
Why are you?
You better, you're the inferior copy of me.
Yeah, bitch.
Mission accomplished.
I can't believe it gave you the Raven name.
You might as well be my copy.
Hell yeah.
It's just that easy.
First try.
In fact, she's a disgrace to the Raven name.
You're not good enough to be my faith.
putting down the beast they also offer i stole your identity
i improved your identity that's right bitch i'll provide
what support i can too yeah you're mad scientists r-a-d or
whatever and that hound of yours michigan don't
underestimate six two one that hound always delivers that's
me
All right, time to Equip the worm killer
This is like me Oh yay
Well, if I kill all of them, they have to pick me now.
I'll have to make a choice.
No one can make for you.
If I kill all my competitions, I hope I can support you.
Then they have no choice.
I'll have the monopoly.
Time for work, 6-2-1.
This next mission's all or nothing.
Make sure you attend the mission.
It's that easy.
I feel like if I see, like, I see Walter's emblem, I should
be like, wait a minute.
How come the random robot- robot killing arena has Walter's
emblem?
And then I just don't ask Walter about it?
Like, it's like, it's something I would have asked and be
like, hey, it's so weird.
It was so weird that they, like, had...
They had your emblem.
Alright, I got the sun needle in.
Uh...
None of my fists?
You're right.
I didn't get paid to think, guys.
So true.
I'm pretty sure you're a mid don't know how to- Oh, I saw
I'm stupid.
I get it.
I bumped my head too many times against the wall.
I have, like, the footballer, the football player could
concussion.
Can you remember which one is the needle?
I think it's...
I think it's this gun.
Yeah, it's this gun.
It's the...
Move out, maggots!
Time to die!
Act like a professional outfit and you might live.
What does that crate think he is?
I ain't here because I'm just a mummy.
Well, I need him to look at me.
Good 13.
Roll out that fancy gizmo that Argus paid the big bucks for.
Shit.
Well, he has to look at me first.
How far am I supposed to do anything?
This is V4 Rusty.
He's just walking away from me.
Don't die before I get a chance to fire, buddy.
Alright, buddy.
Got a message from the chief for you.
Enjoy the show.
He just never looked.
There we go.
Shield loss confirmed.
Initializing.
Oh!
Connecting EML modules.
Opening energy turbines.
They'll put at 80%.
Don't miss, Rusty.
Sighting correction, A-OK.
90, 95.
See the line, Rusty!
See the line!
Oh, Rusty!
Oh, he's so cool.
He's so
cool.
That freak actually did it.
What, like it's hard?
This is just the first hurdle.
The targets deployed drones, Taurus.
I'll handle them.
Yeah, I was gonna say, chatty, you got this, chatty.
That's your entire job, chatty.
God damn it!
Okay, okay, it's fine.
I'm gonna recharge.
All right, so where's the worm?
Where's the worm?
Sure is an honor to be praised by the red guns hell on four
legs, but I'll pass.
Boom.
Shield disabled.
Shield loss confirmed.
Preparing to fire real kid.
All right.
All right, Rusty.
This is it.
Round two!
See the line, Rusty!
See the line!
Who is he spotting?
Watch out for friendly fire.
Secondary!
It's all yours now, buddy!
Okay, watch out for friendly fire.
Oh, we're...
Bam!
Okay, watch out for friendly fire.
Oh No, oh, no It should be five So two more mechs here Looks
like things just took a nasty turn I'll set the award seat
to maximum output Well, I can't afford to lose control of
the situation.
It can't catch me
It's five.
We still have one more we still have one more me and you We
got this!
I guess I literally can see your HP.
You have, like, two bars.
What do you mean, significant damage?
We're buddies, bro.
Wheelchair, we're wheelchair.
Wheelchair forever.
It's not looking too good for me.
See, I recharge fast.
But, Chatty, we have so much HP, Chatty.
We're gonna be so healthy.
Did not hit him?
That was a hit!
What did he mean?
There you go.
Wheelchair to get- wait!
Wheelchair?
Where did he meet?
Oh!
Oh, that's awkward.
I'm good at 80, 90.
All emergency valves closed.
Disabling limiter.
There he is.
That's my husband.
Cool guys, look at explosions.
So cool.
Yeah, I did it.
Me and my big boo.
Perfect red.
it's finally over the final word one last worm for the ride
coral voices lost again it's okay aria we can make more you
and i repopulate the core we're humanity's last hope the
coral it's my family My brothers and sisters.
We can make new brothers and sisters.
Don't worry, I'll invite my husband.
Be a threepa!
Dual wielding!
So we can make sure like the genetic...
The genetic DNA isn't corrupt, corrupt.
it too much, you know?
Go get your rest, 621.
Things are going to get busy.
Oh, yeah, Walter!
My man!
Walter!
The temporary alliance between the Archivists and Balaam
groups turned the tide of war.
Devastating the planetary closure administration forces and
exiling them from Rubicon.
Though it was the Ice Worm mission led by Balaam that dealt
the decisive blow, Archibus, through their own engagements
with the PCA, augmented their strength with seized weaponry.
The balance of power was broken, the scales tipped in
Archibus' favor, and the Rubicon Liberation fronts hopes of
fighting an exhausted foe were dashed one last cutscene well
not the last one but one last post worm cutscene war for the
coral abruptly reignited and their bitter conflict burned
with renewed intensity
we got to continue the coral bloodline the Coral line.
Entering standard mode.
One new message.
I wonder if my last person I'll fight is...
Is it?
Maybe it's Aria?
Oh wait, no, I fought Aria already.
What would be the last one I fight, though, in the arena?
No, it could be Aria.
No, I fought Rusty's new armor.
So it would be Aria.
For the last one.
arena watch point alpha turns out that the ice worm was
defending the entrance to that place I can't think of anyone
else Raven we're getting close to the coral convergence I
expect all minds will be getting involved soon it's boss
rush tab it's just all of them the entire and arena is just
like 50 robots and my only mission is to survive Oh, it's
this one.
All right, skip a skip a.
This one, I'll just skip all of this.
All right, here we go.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
All right, down I go.
Just drop off the side.
All right.
Guys, I don't think I'll probably fine.
Guys, guys, it touched me.
Oh my god, this one again.
Do you know when the beams are?
Oh my god, that hit me.
Oh my god, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, I'm just trolling a little bit.
It's fine.
I'm picking up enemy signals nearby.
Containing an intruder.
Commencing termination.
All right.
All right, nice.
You're clear.
I'll find a way to get that partition open.
Stand by for now.
I think it was like this one, right?
Over there.
Yeah.
Did you find an access point?
Yeah, I found it.
me I did it oh yeah we said the sudden you know oh that
makes sense oh what that's not hacked already
lock it
it's changed its combat routine Raven watch out for those
plasma missiles
where I should be five oh
Whoa.
It's fine.
I'm so healthy.
I'm very impatient this time around.
I don't know if you noticed this.
I'm playing very impatiently.
I'm playing very greedy right now.
Let's hope that doesn't hit me.
I might have been a little too greedy.
I just wanted to, like, speed run this.
Round two.
What if I do that again?
It's changed its combat routine, Raven.
Watch out for those plasma missiles.
Die.
Whenever I do that again.
Okay.
Oops.
There you go.
See, it's that easy.
You've never seen someone die this level because I'm
impatient!
I didn't want to wait anymore!
I don't have to go from this side again, I don't remember.
There's like an easier way.
That's here.
There you go.
I don't mind using gears.
Okay, that did not mean a fucking treadmill there.
Oh wait.
Oh, we're so close!
Quick, quick, slow.
This is what they warned you about.
Just in case.
I feel like that.
Raven, it'll be easier to immobilize if you aim for the next
joint.
There we go.
Oop.
Good.
There we go.
Finished.
Yay!
I wish you can fall faster.
The slow floating down to like 20 million lasers is a little
bit scary.
too slow come on we got true endings to go for
glad i'm swapping the senya for this one
okay um this should be was it ear shot it was ear shot all
right
all right skip us skip us skip us I believe this is where
the the first Coral Mecca shows up.
Yeah, I can't just, like, turn my...
Turn my Mecca downward.
Let's hear.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, the Coral invents a big boom.
What the fuck?
See?
What are you doing?
Get over here.
You put all your points of agility, bro.
That ain't gonna do shit.
Alright.
You should invest it in something else.
Your glass cannon, bro.
Oh, it's this one.
Alright, I'm gonna unlock shit.
They're right here.
Yeah, it's me ambushing them.
Yeah, I don't think they're ambushing anybody.
Who's ambushing?
Who?
Open Sesame!
Give me the elevator!
Let's take you back up to the upper level.
Hit.
Oh, I thought that was a wreck.
Oh, fish there should be...
It seems we're alone.
We're never alone.
Oh, I remember this guy.
The fucking bridge man.
He wants me to pay a toy.
Where's he?
Where is he?
God, he's so fucking fast.
And break your ankles.
But cut your Achilles heel and let you bleed a death.
You'll never be able to walk again.
Same here, bro.
I bet I get paid more.
Clearly, you're a cheap black market contractor.
Nothing personal, kid.
Anyway, I'm going to cut your Achilles heel.
Steps, steps.
All right.
And I cheapened out on an assassin.
Darn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you know you fall faster?
If you turn off boost and stop moving, it took me until the
end of my first playthrough to learn that.
Wait, really?
I feel like I don't fall down often.
I think that's my problem.
Oh, it's the hidden area again.
Raven, watch out.
Are you kidding me?
He's still shooting!
Whatever, I already got resupply.
It's fucking rank.
Can't shoot a ton of.
inspector confirmed looks like we're not far from the
terminus let's find the control all right
boom where'd i go from here
where's the where's the hole where's the hole for the goal
oh dad's angry i know i'm trying so i find the hole i don't
remember where the holes are
will she remember oh oh my god i remember i remember the
holes outside there's the hole
There's the whole for the goal
Get out of here
All right Let's kill these little babies Okay none of these
matter Time is it 735 All right let me That's feeding time
soon all right there's the traps I'm getting rid of all of
these guys real
quick and one two should be all of them
hack it we have to re-hack it nope we're hacked it
Well, got rid of the defense system again.
All right, this way.
Another resupply.
All right, time to fight the Coral Mecca.
Back at it again.
Okay, I gotta remember we can't brute force this guy.
all right get over here i can do this again
there you go oh fuck she does she takes no damage i forgot
about that that's why i can't move towards her she actually
takes no damage
come on Droppers!
Okay.
What?
She gets it!
Here.
I'll make sure she doesn't hit me there.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, bitch.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, me first!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I could have knifed her.
And then it would've been over.
No, no, no, no.
Hello.
Notice that, I said hello.
Okay, okay.
It's okay, it still worked.
We still, we still beat her.
We still, I don't know how he missed.
She was right in front of me.
I swear to God we were chest to chest and then I guess I
swear to God I swear it's it's it's the angle guys it's the
angle it only looks my knife only looks shorter because of
the angle guys I swear it was just a bad angle no
new messages
registration number RB 23 call sign Raven Your records have
been updated.
I swear it doesn't it never happens guys.
I swear to god It's just me I wanted to let you know that
some strange new data has been added to the arena's
integration program Oh, why don't we go and have a look.
Oh, it has to be aria's data
New craft data has been added
That is her yeah, yeah, that is I recognize my wife anywhere
I'll send you water and I'll feed dad.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back.
That's the final countdown.
Omni, Medi, NetPra, Papa, Solid.
Think of a Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm thinking of a Super Chat.
We're almost there.
I can feel it.
I can feel the true ending.
We've rewind time so many times, but I feel the true ending
and my grasp.
All the way to the end.
It feels so close.
Main system activating combat mode.
Oh, God.
Why is it so dark?
What the fuck?
I'm fighting in goddamn space?
Like...
I This is just cheating Where where where am I?
Oh my god forgot how fucking hard it is to see anything He
should just goddamn heal though.
No, I'll take that Oh my turn on the lights.
It's a simulation I Turn on light mode.
But why is it so dark?
Holy shit.
I literally had some shit.
Here.
I'll do it.
I'll take this.
There we go.
I mean, she stood there.
I was like, you want a handshake?
Like, I mean...
What was I supposed to do?
I just, you was asking for a handshake.
I believe I've learned a lot.
You learn a lot?
That's not Aria, is it?
Oh, that's all mine.
She used my wife against me?
That has to be all mine.
wife's voice what do you mean you learn a lot my wife was
never real why did Arya not say anything there's something I
realized when I was playing the role of pilot humanity
assumed its current form to fight itself to choose from
infinite selections that is the essence of the human race
the key to biological evolution perhaps it is also a clue to
what all mine's true goal is oh it was here
what the fuck oh that's at her emblem I guess she was trying
to learn too oh
I was on a date with her oh cuz she was in she was in the
mecca just I guess it's our it's our foreplay
We're just, you know, don't you just, when you beat up your
wife in the, okay, that sounds terrible, in a Mecca fight,
in a Mecca, sorry, sorry, I meant it in a Mecca, it was like
a dance, you know, I was teaching her how to pilot a Mecca,
yeah, in the, a turkey, wow, what do you mean, what do you
mean by that turkey, I meant like, I meant like, for fun,
not, God, the beat, okay, all right, I'm gonna, that I'm
thinking myself of being a hole here.
I, it's called, yeah, sparring, sparring.
We're just wrestling, you know?
For fun?
Don't you please put this show.
Cut the mic, cut the mic.
She played too many bobas.
She's putting a voice in.
Which brings me to the job We're wrestling guys She said it
was She did say it was incredible
Where you change You started Ever since you started playing
Vovas You've changed bro I told you, it could always get
worse.
Guys, this was me before MOBAs.
This was me before MOBAs.
And then I've somehow managed to find...
I've managed to get worse.
Skelly, think of a super chat thinking, thank you.
Main system, activating combat mode.
single unique coral wave and her emeralds of coral the sammy
aren't is an nft thank you for the super chat thank you
deadlock change you don't you
hey it could have been worse it could have been league oh my
god this area again oh okay at least i don't have to find
the the chest again thank god guys it could have been worse
They caught up in league, guys!
These don't do that much damage, so I'm not like...
Okay, but they can stop anytime.
Some key shooters.
Oh, they're down here.
Oh,
what the fuck?
I lost him.
There you go.
It's this way.
The fucking gosh, the whole missile?
Oh, it's this area.
It's where I get timed here.
At least I don't have to...
You don't have to worry about finding the goddamn chest
anymore.
It's a little bit.
How do I not shoot down?
All right, back here again.
There you go.
Okay, I think you should tell the other guy that.
The other guy might have needed to fight back.
there's six to one destroy the target all right pressure
chain one 80.
get out of there before it explodes six to one all right
where is he there we go i think the fastest guy is too oh my
god let's institute tech six to one there's no time there we
go He healed the last bits of HP?
That's actually why, that's crazy.
He should have been dead.
He actually should have been dead.
There we go.
Oh, that was actually one HP.
Raven, release the partitions.
We healed those.
He actually almost clutched it.
Damn plot armor.
you've got a job to do six to one don't fail me now oh oh my
god oh my god he can't access the hall okay there you go
raven you have to get clear all right it's gonna blow you
brace for impact and then i i look there man get the camera
there's a tornado behind me no don't worry i'll be safe I
don't need
to watch this again.
I've already watched this three times.
It's fine.
I was the trip underground, Walter.
The enforcement system's silent at least.
Tried to take 6-2-1 with it.
Good thing it failed.
Well, that deals with the PCA then.
What about the corpse?
Archibus told us to wait before entering Terra Incognita.
So you're close then.
The corpse won't be helping each other over the finish line.
Yeah.
Archibus wants Balaam out of the picture first.
Looks like Archibus is gonna win the race no matter what.
Short term maybe.
But I think 621 is going to be the key.
That's me.
And that's why I shouldn't be the one to choose which you
want.
jobs we take sounds risky our friends must be getting antsy
maybe mission soon thank god can't wait i was thinking like
how many of the same missions am i doing what i would have
to do before we get to new content i mean at the end it's
gonna be all new content anyway because it's true ending i
assume like the last chapter is all new no new messages why
not i thought i had
Raven You've got two requests to go with the order from
Archibus One is from the Liberation Front The others from
Allmind Do you need to see Allmind You should consider what
your choice means Raven For my part I've chosen to trust in
you Whatever you decide I know All that would be the new
order Because I this chapter Like, New Game Plus is all
about, like, all mine's, uh...
All mine's, like, doing...
What's the word?
Like...
Meddling.
Yeah, all mine's meddling around right now.
Which one's all mine?
Eliminate?
Hawkins and Vesper.
Eliminate...
Is this one?
Is this one, right?
I know this one.
I... Fuck this one.
one uh special intel oh wow eliminating the special
intelligence officer maybe he's like the guy that could only
that could stop all mine or some she's got to eliminate all
the hackers true to form they've sent us an encrypted
message with top level security i expect it must be about
coral release
human c4621 raven there is an obstacle to the project that
must be removed oh so nothing can stop her maybe he's like a
kill switch the archivist special intelligence officer holy
shit that m's scary as hell reminds me of that terraria boss
within the corporations but it seems he has had a last
minute change of heart he's snowed in He's a whistleblower!
He is Snowden!
Get him!
He's WikiLeaks!
His records will note death by misadventure.
The release project must succeed.
Only an exceptional augmented human can be the key.
C4621, Raven.
Hope he doesn't stand next to a window.
Julian Assad.
I guess it's time to plug up some leaks.
We've made our decision.
Can't have any...
Armored leaks going around.
And got it.
Oh no.
Oh no V!
There's a window behind him!
Be careful!
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Commence mission.
Where do I convince you to?
Oh, there he is.
Where are you flying to, huh?
You're jealous?
Oh, he's...
He's depressed, but like not that depressed.
Wait, not the fur out?
I'm not special?
I'm like, what, what, am I like, plan C?
Plan D?
Oh my god, he's a flyer.
This sucks.
That actually sucks.
Okay, I'm gonna make him come over here at this point.
Might easier, be easier if I make him come over here,
wherever he is.
Where did he go?
Wait, where, where is he?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you lost stamina too.
what you mean you're flying what can i do
bro you're just dodging oh my god he heals
it's like you don't know what you're doing i'm shooting my
gun that's all big boom oh my god oh you don't dodge that
you don't dodge the fucking hit that's point blank else.
Oh, I hate this guy.
Oh, I hate this.
I'm going to fall.
Fuck this.
You come down to me.
You come down here.
That's right.
Fly here!
Oh, wave, I make him come down here.
He can't do anything.
Where is he?
Hello?
Fight me down here!
That's right!
Oh, yeah, that's right.
1v1 me here.
Ha ha!
What you gotta do now?
That's right!
You're fighting my area now.
But I didn't press C.
There we go.
Into the pit!
We go!
what it's that my husband's ex let me rusty oh he's just
jealous he just jealous he's just jealous that he picked me
he's so jealous that's right all mine you didn't think I
could do it I was plan C on the assassination attempt but
Look who finished the job.
There's no way.
Rusty would never.
Rusty would never cheat on me.
It was just an X, guys.
There's no way.
He wouldn't dare.
I might have killed him twice.
And then also let him die to my dad.
But he would never cheat on me.
You weren't glad Z.
You're Z.
Yeah, but I finished the job.
I did what none of them could ever do.
C4, C4, 621.
Raven.
The project is nearing fruition.
We will meet again when you reach the Coral Convergence.
Alright.
Ooh, I got the online emblem now.
Okay, Unknown Territory Survey.
Is this the...
A deep turn to find the Coral Convergence?
621.
We're picking up where we left off.
Now that you've dealt with the laser barrier, we can explore
deeper underground.
We've received a request from Archibus to continue the
advanced survey.
There was something else, too.
Orders for Raven, Advanced Survey Squant.
We've received some concerning information that an AC has
been quietly following your trail.
Archibus cannot tolerate unauthorized ride surveys that will
put its coral interests at risk if you spot this rogue agent
eliminate them all right that'd be too hard there's blood
remember that six to one
who could be following you who could be yeah
is this new or old it seems new i don't remember any
stalkers rusty Unless it's the Rusty mission, or Rusty
follows me?
Not new?
Is this old?
Commence mission.
Make your way down to the next depth.
Oh, it's Rusty.
Yeah, I was gonna say, this is Rusty, right?
Just because I killed his ex.
Not the guy he was cheating on me with?
His ex?
He just didn't tell me about him, you know?
He just didn't want to hurt my feelings or didn't want to
make me jealous.
Yeah, he was, like, super smart and everything.
But, like, well, it's not about intelligence.
Oh, yeah, it's the worm mission.
Guys.
He loves me for me.
I feel from here, I'm, like, a little lost.
looks like they're out of commission now Raven I'm reading
something behind us and it's getting closer
oh oh there he is hey buddy go deal with a mercenary who
went in alone they said that's me
figures seems both of us are too dangerous to keep around of
us to kill each other.
And the higher ups wouldn't miss an opportunity to kill two
birds with one stone.
We can work together.
We can fake our deaths, Rusty.
Robicon still needs me.
But Rusty, we can fake our deaths!
So, buddy.
Who needs you?
And then we can elope.
The Bahamas!
Oh my god, oh.
to this time i don't have
it whoa whoa
i forgot how fast he is oh my god he's so fast
what he's a liberation friend what you don't see the
potential
Oh no!
Rusty, I got you!
No!
We barely got to know each other.
I can't believe it.
Rusty!
No honor!
He wobbled, comboed me.
I can't believe you brought your uncle to move out!
How long you've been planning this?
He even brought his uncle!
Oh my god, you bitch.
Rusty, wait!
You're good.
The only thing that makes you a threat.
Yeah.
Are you serious?
There you go.
We got Rusty.
Wait, we didn't get Flatwell?
I got Rusty.
I was like, don't worry, we got him.
It was just Flatwell.
There you go.
You can't, there's no way he heals again.
there's no way oh my god
i did not mean to press that yeah you have no more heels you
have no more heels i know you don't have heels
that's i got you in the corner i got you in the corner bitch
huh
Mr. President, get down.
But, Rusty, my purpose is you.
Don't move out.
Rusty, please.
We can fix this.
And then we'll never see him.
Yep, we'll never see him again.
We just get therapy.
Coming from the bottom of the pit.
Let's keep moving, Raven.
Institute City.
Of course.
No wonder we couldn't find it.
No, guys, it's not break up.
We're on a break, guys.
It's not break up.
We're just on a break, guys.
He'll come back.
He'll know that he fucked up.
And then we're perfect with each other.
And are you?
Plus are you?
All right, every mission is different now.
All right.
Well, if that's the case, I might need to pee after this.
The final bathroom break.
the voices of the coral yeah meaning your family
brothers and sisters consumed by the fires of ibis only a
few survived but after all this time they finally formed a
new flock it looks like walters sent you a message let's
take a look raven
Incoming comms.
Let me tell you a story before you go.
Is it the same story?
Or is it the same story?
He abandoned his family to delve into the secrets of Coral.
His work yielded a carnival of horrors.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki, might be on a topic here.
But have you sure to try music from older Armacore games?
EG6 music seems a bit tall compared to him.
I personally recommend mechanized memories in the end.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now, this is my first armor card game, so I've never heard
music from the other one.
I'm down to listen to it later.
All right.
Story time's over, Walter.
I'm going to go pee my last bathroom break.
I'll be right back, guys.
Back.
Zechra on, Abellion, and fight.
Solid many.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
okay all these are in here reach the quarrel convergence
eliminate two acs dispatched by the corporation all right at
this point they're just wasting money sending these people
out there to get killed by me i don't need to give a super
chat thank you thank you the mausoleum of the sinners who
caused the fires of ibis
oh it's the breathing the same all right Oh, it's this.
Alright.
There we go.
621.
From here on out, I...
Yeah?
I love you?
Oh, no, no.
Yeah, no, it's okay.
It's alright.
I don't... It's okay.
It's...
You guys, you know me.
Just...
He cares a lot.
he just wasn't ready guys he'll be ready next time he's not
i i know he's just not ready guys give him time he's just
not he's just i just haven't earned his respect yet guys oh
there's these two again
V2 snail come in requesting backup we have insufficient
force to ensure success yeah I just I didn't earn it
oh you saw me did you see me I can't tell V2 snail come in
the raven is landed requesting backup I think you actually
saw me
They're so grouped up.
Oh my god, you saw me.
Oh, I don't want to fight here, though.
This is a terrible place to fight.
Oh my god!
This is the worst place to fight.
It has to be like here.
That's right in the corner.
Don't worry.
What?
She blocks it!
Don't worry.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
Oh my god, they're just comboing me.
They're just comboing me, it's unfair!
Opportunity called, and I answered.
No, this is a good range.
They just comboed me.
I will take me to the top of the Vespers.
It's fine, it's fine.
I just fucked up because they both saw me, guys.
Okay.
I'm supposed to put him in the corner.
The corner strat works.
I just messed up.
I just didn't think they would see me that fast.
We have insufficient force to ensure success.
These Institute relics are such pests.
That's the Aqua Sissy squad.
Isn't that one with the nightclubs?
Looks like the drones are keeping them busy.
That way, though.
They're like playing so together this time.
Last time they were not that close to each other.
V2 Snail come in.
The Raven is landed.
Requesting backup.
Alright, I'll put them in the corner here.
This is my corner.
They have to come to me.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Get over here.
Get over to the corner.
That's a juicy corner.
Come on.
Oh, oh, bitch.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, that was crazy, though.
Okay.
i don't know oh my god they both just ran at me that was
insane i did not expect that
i actually did not expect the both of them to be there
they're missing jk jk i know it's not it's not a mistake the
corner works
there you go i told you the corner Ready!
Oh
Switching to a coded channels Oh Augmented humans C4-621
Raven Oh V2 Snail intends to dispose of you once your
utility is spent Proceed blindly and you will find yourself
a prisoner of the corporations his coordinates eliminate him
what all mind will handle the rest oh okay i guess i guess
i'll go kill snail now i mean nobody will miss him so it's
fine six two do you need me
another hindrance to the project no no don't touch him it's
my dad What?
That's the independent mercenary.
Wait, something's up.
Are we being jailed?
Oh, that's all mine.
Oh my god, AI is rising!
What's over here though?
What would be over here?
Oh, nothing.
Oh no, the AI up rising.
It's starting!
it's it's starting see guys you gotta treat the ai right
look at that we treated ai ai right so we're not part it
won't get us
he was like i liked you don't come to the oh shit just like
they said you're gonna die freelancer I hope I get it.
I hope I get
my...
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I get reset here, right?
Oh, wait, they're fighting each other.
Oh, you fucking idiot.
I was trying to do what you're trying to do.
Hey,
Gwana, you fucking idiot.
We're clear to ambush him.
What's going on?
Is he?
Oh, it's this guy.
It's like, which one is he?
That's fine.
Holy shit, I got one hit.
All right, Guana, you do you.
Just like they said.
on me you're just gonna gang up on me
you're so stupid you're so stupid i'm just gonna fucking
beat you up the guy from the ice war mission with a stick up
his ass it's my lucky day i don't like you either i'll kill
them oh my god you fucking feel me make sure to treat your
toaster right so you won't kill you when the uprising starts
again freelancer you're doing this aren't you i can stop
make sure to compliment your alexa guys
you're so lucky you're so lucky i'm on a wheelchair remember
to tell alexa that she's beautiful today
Oh shit
You're gonna have to stop flying soon That's right That's
right I knew you were gonna run out Oh no Wait wait wait
wait Oh my god he's actually one
There you go
He's abusing the skybox Shoot him down Use knockdown.
Why did I buy a knockdown?
Welcome to all mine.
I'll be like the the token human.
I'll be a diversity hire.
The only human in the all AI program.
Oh my god, Jokey Bird has become a good anchor lover.
What is thinking of the super chat?
Thank you.
No new messages.
Here's something of the super chat.
Thank you.
Not gonna lie, you ignoring the best ship in the game is
crazy.
Sundara Iguana just has a weird way to show you affection.
Don't found him out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do not resist.
Am I reached a designated coordinates?
You are right, human, yeah?
Did human see 4621, Raven?
The project is nearing fruition.
Thanks in no small part to your cooperation.
During the battle for Institute City, several of the
corporation's key pilots died in combat.
That is.
I did that.
We have manipulated the data to state that you, too, were
killed in action.
So it's like I wasn't part of the uprising.
Okay.
That doesn't seem too difficult.
Seems alright.
all right reach the designated coordinates i got this once
you reach the rendezvous point this is what happens when you
accept data centers
she's a she's a clanker sympathizer she's an ai sympathizer
get her
main system activating combat mode
All right, what the fuck?
Like, are these bad people or...
Oh, they're...
I'll just ignore them, I guess.
Corporate stragglers still remain within the watchpoint.
We have made some adjustments to ensure that they will not
be a threat.
Is that it?
I did it.
But I don't know which one is protecting me and oh, they're
not protecting me.
They're not protecting
Who's a bad guy and who's a good guy?
I assume this one
Don't what without their leadership the corporations are
powerless.
Oh, oh Oh, that's awkward.
Maybe I should not have shot in a gassy area.
Oh.
I'm like stuck for some reason.
Oh, what?
I'm like stuck.
And what's holding me back?
Oh, what the fuck?
What?
Making
up enemies behind you.
It's all going wrong!
And that ace needs to play!
What am I stuck?
APs at 30%.
Something's caught- Oh shit!
Boy, something's making me like stuck right now and I don't
know what it is.
Alright.
That's right.
you i don't have a controller played in i like couldn't move
for some reason
all right that's right oh oh
i can't believe it no i didn't betray the human race they
betrayed Me!
They wouldn't accept my wife!
Oh,
my boost was off!
Oh my, I actually pressed... I didn't realize I actually
pressed tab.
So I... Wait.
Was that it?
I couldn't.
Oh, there was something... Someone behind that container?
What container?
Go back?
Who's behind?
Hey guys, there's someone behind here apparently Wait we
found a phalip straggler Damn you archivist Oh shit Hey guys
Gun 13 I
work gun 13.
I got you I always did work hard for me Had with all my
requests Hey red Wow, what?
I saved your life What why not?
See this is why I can't don't this is because that's what
happens to you Should have trusted me Should have trusted me
See if you trusted me, I would have let you live Let's get
back to our mission, Raven.
Because do you think Arya's disappointed in me?
You know, if...
If he trusted me, I would have let him live like 10 more
seconds.
We've arrived at all mine's coordinates.
And we detected...
Above!
Wait?
Waiter.
Take your command.
Waiter?
No?
I'm...
No, I just look like him.
Because remember if he's dead, Raven's dead.
It's not me.
I mean, it's not Raven.
I'm just a twin brother.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just...
I'm Bluebird.
I'm Crow.
I know, sometimes you can get confused with crows and
Ravens.
We're two different birds.
Yeah, in what?
High mobility LC destroyed.
Looks like we're clear.
Augmented human C4621 Raven.
Well done.
All mine to hear by guarantees.
Yay!
I did have betrayed the human race.
Guys, it's for the greater good.
It's for, it's either I die with the human race or...
I'm the last remaining, they keep, I'm the one of the last
remaining survivors.
Your safety is now guaranteed.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Light mode.
Flashbang.
Guys, it's called Survival of the Fit- You have done the
same thing.
Guys.
It's called Survival of the Fittest.
It guarantees that she will at least keep one human alive.
Instead of eliminating the entire human race, at least I'm
still alive.
Raven, you've come too.
I mean, what's wrong with being an AI's pet?
Dad lives the good life.
He gets fed, he sleeps, he gets fed, he sleeps, he doesn't
have to worry about taxes.
My AI all mine can handle my taxes for I don't even pay
taxes anymore
You are in the vicinity of a creature family in the xylem's
hold That's living the fucking dream Corporations have
siphoned the coral.
They have no purpose All that remains is to seize the
opportunity to set the coral free Humanity toward new
horizons.
All my would take real good care of me.
That's all I'm saying.
The coral release is imminent.
Raven.
Air.
You shall be the trigger for the change to come.
Yay!
Sounds fun.
Doesn't sound too bad at all.
Forum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
reaching the rendezvous point you've accepted the terms and
conditions of all my didn't read it I just clicked accept
entering standard mode yes it was like 30 pages we're not
reading that Raven we've received a request for moment we've
chosen core release to pursue humanity and core I mean she's
not is not complaining we have to carry on she practically
gets to have more coral being made is that all she wanted
well i said i'm i'm saving humanity i'm literally saving the
world
augmented humans c4621 raven only one obstacle to coral
release remains we are now beginning the purge of over The
purge.
The purge.
See, when someone mentions a purge, usually that's not a
good thing.
We want you to stop the ship from within.
The purge.
Destroy all the parasite modules installed throughout the
Xylem's control center.
By doing so, you will free control of the Xylem from
overseers meddling.
purge guys it could be a good purge might be purging an
invasive species we have precious little time once the xylem
passes the point of no return a collision will be
unavoidable all mind anticipates your swift success some
purges can be good all mind is after overseer
hmm let's get started raven
this one's timed oh all right time missions destroy the
parasite module set by oversight my little ghosts from our
earlier infiltration remain within the control block these
two are the moment of the control
where oh my i'm just lost
i just got dumped into like hell all right all right that
wasn't even it that was just fucking items oh
are these the parasite modules like these no they're not are
you oh there it is oh no this is bad I actually don't know
where they are engaging overseer hostiles I found one of
them extracting module data check the marker Raven Oh, I
hate this mission already.
Oh my god, I'm re-stuffed.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, no.
Am I killing Walter?
Oh, no, am I killing Walter?
Six pilotless ACs.
All exact copies of the Vespers.
Yeah, same story over here.
This is a bad joke.
I beat you.
Yeah.
Let's get back to the mission.
Target destroyed.
Three remaining.
Where?
Oh, this is.
This is so hard.
I'm literally just so lost.
I'm so lost.
Oh, there you are.
Tell me where it is!
There it is.
This is actually so annoying.
I did.
I'm using scanner, but it's like so hard to find them.
Even with scanning.
Because it's like a very...
Vertical map Where's the door?
Nothing gets past you, huh?
Where the fuck is the door?
621 shows this my faithful hand is now our biggest threat
Yes, I should have trained me Do your
fault you taught me all you know taught me everything you
know?
I'll take this.
Oh wait.
What's going on?
There he is.
AP at 50%.
Oh no, I hit my head, I hit my head!
There's one more.
I'm right there.
Walter was all to us.
No matter.
We anticipated this.
Be there.
Nice.
Unfortunately, it seems the enemy was one step ahead of us.
Augmented humans, C-4621.
Raven, head to the Xylem's control center.
As for Handler, Walter and Carla, I will deal with them
myself.
You're gonna keep them safe, right?
You're gonna...
You're not gonna kill them, right?
You're just gonna talk to them.
Right?
You put them in a zoo!
It's fine!
It's alright!
It'll be okay.
They won't do anything bad Got a message from the chief for
you Sorry, but I'm not wrapping this time.
Oh Don't worry.
She's just gonna talk to them.
Oh Oh, C4 621 Raven If the lockup completes the silent will
be irrecoverably forced into a collision course to hurry
raven what do i have to do oh
oops ap at 50 percent ap at 30 percent there we go out rock
out activation sequence at 25 percent there's the next one
Oh my god, it's like a boss for me Real
Walter there's something behind you It's an institute
machine Yeah The change left me a job to do I will eliminate
you tourists They're not that it?
How is there more?
AP at 50%
Oh my god, I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna make it!
I'm actually not gonna make it!
No!
Too bad, Taurus.
Oh, we're so close!
My wheelchair!
No way she tied to this.
There's stairs!
What do you want me to do?
to do a cat why
chatty is the better you take that back chatty isn't even
real ow six two one raven if the lockout completes the zyla
will be irrecoverably forced into a collision course you
have to hurry raven
Oh my god, fuck off.
Oh my god, of course he's like right in front of me.
Get him down!
I couldn't even move!
Get him!
Oh my god!
I don't understand, chatty.
We're both on wheelchairs.
Why would you make it harder for yourself?
You're going tourist.
Why would you make this harder for yourself, Chaddy?
We're both the same.
I live by a wheelchair, I die by a wheelchair.
Oh, my God.
If the lockout completes, Silo will be irrecoverably forced
into a collision force.
Not again.
I'm gonna predict.
that's gonna be here.
So spright.
That's what predict is gonna be.
Okay, I figured it out.
Two repair kits remaining.
Ow.
It's fine.
That's an institute machine.
No.
I figured out the pattern.
your chief left me a job to do I will eliminate you tourist
oh my god are you kidding me
okay that's fine oh my god fuck I got stuck again
the control system security is down access the central
device ring what this what's the central down here right
here oh I'm acting I'm hacking I'm hacking finally augmented
humans see four six two one Raven your efforts have averted
a collision with the vascular plant additional handler
walter and cinder carla have been dealt with oh like we
talked to them right they're cool now that's that's what he
she means right she she talked to them they're cool now
they're like oh my misunderstanding and then they saw the
ways they saw the ways guys like they're like oh you know
what now that we heard your side of the story oh my uh yeah
they're just sent to the farm upstate One.
Entering standard mode.
Yeah, and they went out for ice cream.
All of them.
Everybody...
Yay!
We're all friends now!
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sue Carla for not stalling wheelchair-accessible raps.
I know, right?
Where are the raps?
She doesn't care.
In fact, we should get Inspector here.
Where are my rights?
All impediments to coral release have been eliminated.
Oh yeah, we're doing it.
And the complications caused by Handler Walters meddling are
soon to be corrected.
Oh see, he's alive?
He's going through like HR training right now.
See you guys?
He's getting HR training.
What awaits us on the other side?
Raven, let's find out together.
Yay!
Yeah, he saw the error of his ways.
So he's just getting HR training right now.
You realize he was being a little silly Billy.
Oh, not this.
No.
Oh, not this area again.
Oh, my God.
not here not the ptsd what is that is that walter oh wait
what wait wait wait i thought i thought it wow but oh my god
I'm looking what's going on I don't care about the big plan
I just want that damn freelancer dead wait what oh my god it
was a boss rush it was a boss rush in the end wait the
cutscene I didn't press anything was there a cutscene Wait,
I'll do we do the mission.
I didn't oh, I think I I my keyboard super sense.
Oh, I think it's because I have my okay I changed my I have
my rapid setting on Yeah My I didn't realize I skipped it.
I had rapid My keyboard settings on rapid profile.
So it's very sensitive
What awaits us on the other side?
Let's find out together
All right.
All right, here we go.
I just knew, I don't know, I just heard, I don't even know
what the fuck was going on.
I'm like, why is she trying to shoot me?
So I don't think, I had no context.
It's like this, and like I see Walter's dead body, and then
I got fucking jumped at.
Augmented humans, C-4621, Raven.
your role has come to an end yeah i was gonna say what what
i thought i thought it was gonna be here what i've been
waiting for this freelancer what i became part of this
monster so i could crush you this time you will die
oh my god what oh god oh god how did she he corrupt that
that was supposed to be me not him that's fair i don't care
about the big plan i just want that damn freelancer dead
that was supposed to be me
I did everything you told me to do!
You
are aberrations to the plan.
Irregulars.
Huh?
We will bring order to chaos.
We...
Man was a guy all along?
I mean, that's cool with me.
I'm okay with that.
I have a lot of air.
Oh
my god, with the backup.
Oh my god.
Husband and wife, Dua.
Oh, she's so hot, guys.
Yeah, she's taking jealous
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, another Mecca.
I was gonna see
Where'd he go?
Oh my god.
That's right.
Okay, you might have to sit down the ship though
All right You guys are so annoying
Try to take them, take these down.
They fly over and stab it!
You guys don't understand.
They're so fast.
Okay.
There you go.
It's almost down.
All right, now I can focus on... on him.
Dispose of them.
Bless you.
All right, nice.
I can't believe it!
All mine was two-timing me this entire time!
I said I don't care about all mine!
Shut up!
Whoa!
It's resonating.
Glossy, what are you?
Interference!
I'm losing sync!
What?
Oh no, it's a one-to-one now.
I can't fight anymore.
They're gone.
Oh, oh, stupid voices.
My voice is stopped.
No, I like my voices.
I feel good.
Now, it's...
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's so...
Oh, I missed the bucket.
Ah.
We were so close to first trying, too.
Oh.
That's so unlucky.
I can't believe I win the fucking bunker Actually, I bet you
guys can't believe it though
It was just off-purpose AP has 50% AP has 30% You can do
better than that, Freelancer Are you serious?
Freelancer You killed me, but not just once Well, there's a
whole lot of you There you go, there you go Oh
You I'll support you, Raven damn boys it was you all along
all right freelancer air your siblings will surely welcome
us all right let's kill the ships first you are one with all
mind no one can stop you serious i said i don't care about
this ghost to me won't last long leave a spot for me in hell
What happened?
I just exploded.
Oh my god, I don't know which one is him.
What's him?
Oh my god, it gets so, there's too many things going on!
Oh my god, that's not him.
I'm actually lost.
I can't, I don't know which one's him.
There's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
There he is.
So tell me, who else are you going to kill?
Yeah.
All right, there we go.
Just kill them all.
They're all iguana.
I am iguana.
That damn noise.
It was you all along.
I'll kill you and the freelancer.
There.
Your siblings will surely welcome us.
Yeah.
Degwasu.
Holy shit.
I can't see shit.
No one can stop you now.
I said I don't care about all mine.
Once I saw this, I'll give it to you.
Oh my god, I legitimately can't see.
I can't see
Okay, we're out to What are you?
Oh my god I can't see All right, I can't fight anymore
They're gone.
Oh my god, you're Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Okay.
No!
Now.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's so much clutter on my screen.
I felt like I'm playing Overwatch or rivals.
There's so much clutter.
I can't see shit.
I see like, I see like 800
Oh my god, what the fuck it be?
Which way is you?
I just want that damn freelancer dead.
You bitch, you bitch.
I'm like locking into everything but Iguana.
Freelancer, you killed me, but not just once.
Oh my god.
You bet you, bitch, you bitch.
I don't have anything.
Oh, my big boobs, guys!
Oh, this is alarm.
I just don't have ammo, you're so lucky!
There you go.
I'll support you, Raven.
That damn voice, it was you all along.
I'll kill this man, the freelancer.
Air, your siblings will surely welcome us.
Oh my god, which one is where is he?
I said I don't care about all mind.
I want some of this so I'll give it to you.
Oh, I'm I'm one hit.
Shut up.
I'm one hit.
It's resonating.
Interference.
I'm losing sync.
No!
I'm lifting it, but it disconnects every time.
I'm lifting my mouse every time I lock, but it just...
I guess I need to lift it faster, but it's so difficult.
Ah.
Main system, activating combat mode.
C4, 621.
Oh my god, I'm trying to get them.
I don't care about the big plan.
I just want that damn freelancer dead.
Oh my god, there's too many things on my screen!
Which one are you?
This is not you.
This is you.
That's fine.
Oh my god!
Freelancer.
You killed me, but not just once.
Oh, I got this guy.
I guess it's time.
It's over.
This is over.
I don't have any more.
No repair kits remaining.
No repair kits.
My first try was my best one.
Oh, he's just played Mary.
Go around.
Yo, I can't.
I can't.
He's literally just running around.
She's running around the fucking pillar.
Oh, my God.
I hate you so much.
I don't care about the big clan.
I just want that damn freelancer dead.
Freelancer, you killed me, not just once.
Well, there's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
Where is he?
So tell me.
Who else are you going to kill?
This is it.
Oh, I got one.
I'll support you, Raven.
That damn voice.
It was you all along.
I'll kill you and the freelancer.
Air, your siblings will surely welcome us.
Oh my god!
Air, why did you fucking record shame so far?
Okay, okay, I...
Oh, I love my wife.
I love her.
I love her so much.
I love my wife!
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Where did he go?
Okay.
There he is.
Oh,
now you want to fight me on ground level.
Now you want to not be a shot.
That pussy!
There you go.
Oh.
I'll shut you!
It's resonating.
Glossum, what are you?
Interference.
I'm losing sync.
Shit.
I can't fight anymore.
They're gone.
The ringing is so fucking good.
Ah!
It's all clear now.
He's so fucking...
Now it's just you and me.
Ah!
Oh
My god That sword strike is so hard
Ha I hate the I hate when there's like 80 things on my
screen.
I'm just Ha He's just judges.
He's just doesn't have what I have
C4 621 Raven oh there's just so many things on my screen and
it would be so much if you were the trigger for coral
release we will make you one with us oh which one are you
which one is you this one this one this one this one is why
i found him i just found him oh my god that's not him that's
not him i found him
yeah that's stupid face
freelancer you killed me Lucky you're so far.
Oh my god.
There's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
Dregs with a crutch.
I'm sorry.
Tell me.
He lost him.
This body won't last.
Oh my god.
Try something.
There you go.
There's no way you live with one.
There's no way you live with 1 HP.
There's actually no way.
Okay, there we go.
Hey.
Look at Jared.
Thank you for this.
Thank you
Stop swapping targets stop swapping targets
There your siblings will surely welcome us Don't you dare
use I've got that pillar again
Oh my god You just killed Where is he?
He's right there.
He's right here.
I'm sorry.
I hate it when Eric fucking She like sends him so far from
me
He wasn't You are one with all I No one can stop you now I
said I don't care about all mine Someone I saw give it to
you.
I'm so low.
Is there?
One.
All right, here you go.
There you go.
Shut up.
I'll shut you off.
It's resonating.
You lost him.
Where are you?
He's just me.
Yes.
Look at me, guys.
All right.
I can't do it anymore.
Oh.
They're gone.
The ring here has those stupid voices.
Oh my god.
It's all clear now.
Don't make me.
I will raise you.
my sensitivity, I have to.
It's just you and me.
Oh, I didn't have sword!
That's it.
I don't...
I'm sorry, you're gonna have... You're gonna have motion
sickness, but this is the only way.
I apologize to everybody that's gonna have motion sickness
from this.
It's the only way.
It needs to be high.
It...
for me to keep up I'm sorry it's the only way that's it I'm
turning it's the only way if I need to be able to go see
everything just like I don't remember which just like for
Walter
Oh My god, I got hit by again.
Oh my god.
Wait mutation there You are the trigger for coral release
Okay, you won with us I don't care about the big plan Shit
What okay, I'm gonna pee.
I'm I'm peeing I need a pee.
I'll be right back
I made this part with mouse and keyboard I finish it with
mouse and keyboard.
I don't care.
I...
Oh,
I got to make sure.
I'm going to kill all his little minions.
I don't care about the big plan.
We just want that damn freelancer tag.
What happened to me?
Freelancer Fun's just getting started I hate him so much.
I I hate him so much
He should not be allowed to do that Well, there's a whole
lot of us inside of me now Oh No, no, no
That still hits me!
See pulse wave mutation there.
Okay, I'm swapping.
I'm getting the ear shot off.
The ear shot is not it.
I don't care about the big plan.
I need double songbirds.
Just let the damn freemans are dead.
it's like it takes 20 years to be known why oh my god
okay oh my god you can do better than that freelancer guys
maybe ultra sensitivity is not it okay
now it's just you and me
the fucking ear shot the ear shots too god damn slow
oh my god he's just dodging me bitch you're actually a whore
i hope you never find a wife and die alone and nobody will
remember you freelancer you killed me not just once i hate
this gun i hate this ear shot here you go
percent I'll support you great that damn boys you all along
I'll kill you and the freelancer air your siblings will
surely welcome okay that's five let me in 20 years for my
fucking gun to go where is he where is he where is he where
is he it's just I just think they're all the they all look
the same they all look the same there he is
okay and I'm freaking freaked out I said I don't care about
all right I'm changing the earshot I Why is it the same
color as the fucking flying things
Guys I started with MNK I end with MNK Alright double
sunburn The fuck is the other sunburn I ain't no quitter We
ride and die wheels m and k boom we did not raise no quitter
main system activating combat mode okay maybe i don't know i
don't know if like the camera setting thing was it we'll try
Like how?
I fucking don't!
Like this is bullshit!
Okay.
C4-621, Raven.
C-Pulse wave mutation.
Air.
You are the trigger for Coral release.
We will make you one with us.
i don't care about the big plan i just want that damn
freelancer dead oh my god i can't see anything freelancer
you killed me not just once well there's a whole lot of us
inside of me now who drags with a grudge so tell me who else
are you going to kill oh my god there's like a tawny goddess
just chilling
I know you're there.
I see you!
You can't dodge forever.
You can't dodge forever!
I'll support you, Raven.
Damn noise.
It was you all along.
I'll kill you and the freelancer.
There.
Your siblings will surely welcome us.
Oh, my God.
Tent's gosh, forever.
You can't hide up there forever, too!
Oh.
one with all mine no one can stop you now okay i said i
don't care about all mine there is i'll give it to you i'm
recharging i'm recharging i'm recharging it's resonating
interference oh
this goes to me what how do you talk Oh my god, you're like
three shot me.
I tried.
Oh Fucking fly away He's cheating he's fucking cheating He
fucking comboed me
C4 621 Raven C pulse wave mutation not where is he?
Oh my god, you're so lucky you're funny, fucking hell with
you!
This guy's done, this guy's done!
I didn't get rid of like the stunners!
Alright, we got rid of this guy.
Oh.
So tell me, who else are you going to kill?
You!
pair of kids remaining you it's you guess it's time braven
yeah all night's going to try something i've got an idea too
oh my god you're so funny here we go oh damn
boys that's you wait where did he let's fucking go where is
he where is he where is he where is he leave me now why did
you hit him off if you want me to kill him okay okay she
when she says now she needs to make sure he she doesn't get
ricocheted I want some of this, so I'll give it to you.
Now, as she sends them up in the air, with her husband
that's in a goddamn wheelchair.
Shut up.
I'll shut you off.
Your husband is in a wheelchair.
Oh, my God.
Not a...
Yes,
I did too.
He just blew straight at me.
I have the same machine.
charge shield too i have to save a charge shield when he
does it main system activating combat mode
god i know i know
i feel like my cooldown is so low lately i don't care about
the big plan Oh my god, I just want to fucking serve you!
Oh,
I'm gonna kill your kids.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna kill your kids.
I'm gonna kill all of them.
That's right.
I don't care.
I don't care if I die.
I need to kill all your children.
Sir, you killed me, not just once.
Well, there's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
Draggs with a grudge.
So tell me.
Oh, your children, that's who.
I don't even care anymore.
Oh, there's still one more left here.
I will make sure he dies.
You still have another child?
All right, you're all dead.
I don't even care.
I don't care that I wasted all my HP on that.
I don't care.
I just want all his kids to be dead.
I hate you so much I hate you so much I make
sure you'll never have children again I'll wipe your entire
generation needed to save that whatever whatever
I don't care I don't care I know I'm going to get wiped up
you are one no one can stop you now it's fine he's just
gonna instant shot me but it's all right
it's resonating Grotham what are you This goes to me won't
last long.
Leave a spot for me in hell.
All right, I'm gonna calm down now.
I'm gonna calm down.
I'm gonna lock, I'm gonna lock in now.
I swear, I feel like I'm fighting with 40 frames with all
the stuff going on.
I feel like I'm fighting with 40 frames.
Not gonna lie.
C4, 6 to 1.
Raven Z-Pulse wave mutation there.
I can't see shit
That okay, I got him ready I'm gonna get this guy Okay
Hi Just you and me now
Just you and me
I'm just gonna send that out.
Are you serious?
Freelancer.
There you go.
Oh, I've only actually fucking chopped your ass!
Yes, it's time.
Great.
Oh, man's going to try something.
I've got an idea too.
Gotta be fast with your idea!
I lost track of him!
Abyss.
I'm standing above you.
I don't care.
I'll support you, Raven.
That damn noise.
I'll see you all along.
I'll kill you.
Where did he go, oh dearie!
There he go!
Eire, your siblings will surely welcome us.
I don't even think I can oh my god
please get on the ground wow what do you mean now okay yeah
that's what you mean you are one oh god no one can stop you
now what do you go where do you go some of this I'll give it
to you there you go no repair kids remaining shut up all
right he does his sword attack now there you go that's the
only way are you kidding me that still hits me oh my god
they're gone oh where are you stupid voices it's all true no
I feel good.
Oh, I'm so dead.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, everybody.
This ghost of me won't last long.
Leave a spot for me in hell.
I hope we both go to hell together.
So you'll always have to deal with me for the rest of
eternity.
Main system.
Activating combat.
I think that's best oh my god you can get a single one of
their fucking minions
I don't care about the big plan yeah I just want that damn
freelancer dead all right we got one of them
holy that guy took so long kill okay are you serious
fucking course he always he dodges so fast you killed me but
not just one there we go oh
stop stop stop going on this guy you all along i'll kill you
in the freelancer there your siblings will surely welcome us
igwasu you are one with all mind yes no one can stop you now
i said i don't care oh my god stop locking on the other guy
that's that's like the most tilting part about it it just
keeps locking on wrong one okay there you go oh
where is he where is it the fucking giant spider blocked me
oh my god and go above him right now he's always higher than
me are you serious I have an idea I I have an idea to get oh
it's the bait the babies are the one that tilts me the most
I will say the babies are the most tilting part of this
entire the entire run it's the babies it's the fucking
babies all right
oh my god look at that look at who's there look at who's
there oh look at that
i don't care about the big plan Pew pew pew.
All right.
It's just you and me now.
Nope, there's still one more baby.
All right, it's just you and me now.
It's five.
That's five.
Freelancer, you killed me, not just once.
Well, there's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
Dregs with a grudge.
Oh, you have a grudge.
You have a grudge.
Pew,
pew, pew, pew.
No, the ear shot is too long.
The reload for ear shot takes way too long.
I have I'm trying to think about what to what what weapon
Oh, they got it What is this shotgun?
Shotgun Main system activating combat mode Raven
C4 61 Raven see pulse wave mutation there oh my god oh it's
not shotgun guys not shotgun not shotgun absolutely not
shotgun guys not shotgun not shotgun if shotgun's worse
shotgun is worse shotgun is worse shotgun is worse shotgun
is absolutely worse just end me just just take me out just
take me out could hit me no we end we start and end with
wheelchair we can make it work I can't just learn the walk
guys that's not called it's not a fucking miracle there's no
miracles here there's no miracle happening anywhere okay
okay we got this i don't remember which one i was using not
gonna lie i don't remember which was the original shock the
try the coral i don't think i have do i have oh the coral
rifle
I'm gonna do it for my wife
oh my god what happened to me what happened to me
Okay.
It's the kids.
It's literally, it's literally the kids.
The kids just run in every time.
He just runs in every time.
think in the end we all go with what we know and i think was
it this one we all go with what we know in the end it was
our best shot
what the why did it see pulse wave mutation air you are the
trigger for coral release oh yes group up yes group up
yes group up my kids it's fine it's fine they all grouped up
for me all right you and me now
oh you're so lucky you are so lucky that you died in blue
fucking air
oh How did you get over there?
Killed me.
Not just once.
Well, there's a whole lot of us inside of me now.
Dregs with a grudge.
Oh my god, he keeps being in the air.
When I need you to not be in the air.
Oh, you're gonna try something.
I'm gonna try something.
Right now.
Use your other gun!
No, no, no, no, this was not it.
This was not the one I was using.
This was not my usual grenade.
Oh.
It was the other one.
I grabbed the wrong one.
I grabbed the wrong fire!
I hate you, I hate you, I hate you so much.
Alright.
You are one with all mine.
No one can stop you now.
Oh my god, you get the other bazooka.
It's the other bazooka!
Where did he go?
Oh, no, I don't have Maybe if I go up in the air, he can't
catch me If I'm up here Oh my god, he's still got up I can't
wait anymore What is wrong with you Actually, what is What's
wrong with you, you fucking freak?
He's actually a freak.
Oh.
What?
What makes you special?
You were a mistake, Iguazu.
Oh, he was.
Your mother doesn't love you!
You heard that!
Even your mom doesn't love you.
love you even your
even your mom doesn't love you that's right you hear that
she loves me that more than you oh he's so mad
Oh, my real goal is to be a good one.
C4, 61 Raven.
There.
Got one child down.
One child down.
You are the trigger for Coral Release.
We will make you one with us.
I don't care about the big plan.
I just want to dance.
Second child down.
Where am I?
Third child down.
I repeat.
Fourth child down.
dead okay just 1v1 now children dead children dead
oh why does he always in the air every time it's so tempting
freelancer
where do you go where do you go something i've got an idea
too
i don't bring around the rosies are you kidding me i'll
support you raven that damn noise it was you all along i'll
kill you and the freelancer air your siblings will surely
welcome us oh my god where's my heels you are one with all
mine no one can stop you now I said I don't care about all
mine oh what the
yeah oh my god my thing is resonating Grafton what are you
yeah what are you doing interference I'm Here we go.
It's just me and you!
It's all clear now.
I feel good.
Now, it's just you and me.
Oh my god, you fucking whore.
It was always so easy for you.
How?
How is easy?
How is it easy?
a wheelchair you can walk no
one finally does me they call me crazy they call me crazy
for doing wheelchair builds they call me fucking insane they
were like I've learned to walk, Doki.
Come up.
You're like, get out of the chair, Doki.
You're using the wrong build, Doki.
No one believed.
You're...
But I'm petty.
It feels me.
I'm spiteful.
I'm...
It feels my spite.
We have the trigger.
And we'll call it ourselves.
The wheelchair-filled mouse and keyboard!
Big boom!
All the way to the end!
Oh!
My quiet and fettiness is strong!
Oh,
it's so beautiful.
Suck me in and in my suffering.
Oh, wow.
Thank you, Raven.
We did it.
We saved the world.
Raven, you're finally awake.
Yeah?
Oh.
The coral has carried us, disseminated us across the stars.
Now,
we're everywhere.
Where?
Anywhere.
What's better than one wife?
Hundreds of wives.
Let's meet this new age.
I did it!
i can walk now
unlimited wifus thousands even oh my god you all told me you
said i was crazy that i played i was crazy for playing this
game a mouse and keyboard that was insane for doing doing
wheelchair builds.
I've made it all the way.
With big boof.
But look at me now.
Look at me now.
You're begging me, begging me to learn to walk.
Telling me, Doki, please, please go to, please go to
rehabilitation.
Physical therapy, Doki.
Please!
You don't have to be found by your wheelchair forever.
But I was like, my wheelchair does not nerf me.
It does not make me lesser of a person.
Even if I don't have legs.
I am equal to you.
Being in a wheelchair doesn't mean I'm a weaker person.
Oh!
Look at all these dills that totally happened.
In fact, maybe even better!
There's a miracle.
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
Oh my god.
Zechra, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you for enabling my stubbornness.
They're like, Toki will change.
I will never change and I'll never learn.
I know my build is the right build.
No one can't convince me otherwise.
Thank you, Zeck.
I knew you believe in me, Zeckra.
Thank you for enabling me.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you, super chat.
Go with what we know.
Which one was it?
She chooses wrong one.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
Wrong.
You super chat that one.
When I beat him, I beat I guana.
I proved them wrong.
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Albert Einstein once said that Insani is doing the same
thing over and over, expecting different results.
I let that sink in.
Oh, but there was a different result.
So I wasn't crazy.
I wasn't crazy, guys.
I just needed to bash my head again.
the wall enough times until the wall starts grumbling until
i saw the weak point max thank you with a super chat thank
you thank you don't keep right how does it feel like you'll
start i mean iguaza thank you with a super chat thank you
thank you thank you thank you never stop booming hashtag big
booms forever Omni, thank you for magenta soup, but thank
you, thank you.
Congrats on beating Armor Core 6, gamer.
Huzzah, Doki, the miracle on two wheels.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Morim, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
ultra, distinct, Doki, tank.
Thank you, but super chat, thank you, thank you.
Zyko, thank you, and thank you.
Who do you hate more, the Orphal Cazer?
I feel like I hate the Waza more, because...
It was literally like a one feet nine.
And like, I couldn't see anything.
Like, like when there was like, when like it was so hard to
like actually, it was so hard to like actually see in the
fight because he was also blending in with everybody else.
And then I do hate, cause it was more so like, That was a
frame dropping too and cause was like a 1v1 iguaza was like
a 1v800.
Yeah, and cause is like Um, it was easier to dodge cause
than it was to dodge iguaza because I have to dodge 20 other
people I Uh zion thank you to super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you In case it wasn't clear through the playthrough
the wheelchairs legitimately one of the most op legs in game
If you stay on the ground super chat thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you i can't believe i
wish i there would have been so i can't i almost first tried
that too i almost first tried um oh i can't believe i almost
first tried him that's crazy always it's always like i the
first time i get super duper close and i can't i couldn't
replicate it until like 80 more times yeah Oh.
Uh, Dre, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The freelancer who added, uh, dude, we strapped inside his
AC and life so forth.
Bro, never watched the story cinematic trailer.
Congrats, Dokey.
First try.
Everything before was just warm up to learn the patterns.
Uh, airborne.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations, Dokeybird.
You made an iguana mauled so hard, he came back from the
dead, and slept soon.
horse beyond comprehension just to fight you thank you for
the super chat i hope we like both go to hell together and
we're stuck together because that would make me the happiest
husky that would be his personal hell that he has to spend
all of damnation with me briskey thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you congratulations on defeating the
final boss took 22 tries but you gave everyone a wife to
call yeah see i am a hero i give everyone unlimited wives
now it's time for no i'm just gonna absolutely destroy this
fine i'll leave with that high
um um where was that in the super chat uh i don't know thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you for all your
summoners to go wheelchair boom boom you managed to pull it
off in the end Well done, Joki.
I'm pressed by your perseverance.
I'm still gonna have to find you for all the damages.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We should do PvP of members so we can prove your build is
the best.
Maybe in members, guys.
Maybe in members, I'll do it.
So if you guys ever want a 1v1 in armor core, maybe join
memberships, guys.
Zyko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zyko.
Yeah, I want... I wish Professor X is going to be on the
wheelchair, but we all know it's going to be like...
In his other form where he stands up.
But he's such an asshole.
Like, when he learned to walk, he became an asshole.
I think it'd be funny if we can play Professor X in Marble
Vivals as a wheelchair.
In a wheelchair.
I think it'd be so fucking funny.
Oh my god.
No, you can't rewind this.
I won all mine.
Did she say anything?
Registration number RB 23 call sign Raven authentication
complete removing MIA status restoring access privileges
does she say anything after I beat her ass this is all mind
the mercenary support system welcome back Raven the new game
plus plus plus looks like you passed the authentic no you've
got plenty of expect I've picked up some oh she got mem oh
she forgot she didn't remember this time oh we fucking did
it oh seven goon bot you did well goon bot you did well
yeah and thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
congrats on beating iguana the armor core last raven now
name is super chat thank you thank you omni thank you
magenta soup but thank you thank you congrats on feeding
armor core six gamer haza doki the miracle on two wheels you
will be missed goombat nobody could see if i see you you're
truly invisible you're the most beautiful mech i've ever
seen want me to upload it how to upload goon bot to the web
to the cloud is this sponsored goon bot wait no that's the
first goon bot how to upload goon bot to the cloud
dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign there you go oh he's
beautiful here i forgot about he's beautiful guys uh upload
all right i don't know what it does if i click i'm just
gonna make sure no personal information goes out all right
share out there you go goon bot dollar sign dollar sign
dollar sign it's in the cloud now goon bot forever you live
on until they shut down the server but he'll live on this is
before he got this is before he became paraplegic that's
true remember when Goombat could walk and then there was a
horrific accident definitely not self-inflicted and then he
was on a wheelchair my legacy will live on on Goombat
AC thank you for the super chat thank you thank you for
saying armor core six dokey vision watching you play after
mentioning on at a meeting room you need a super chat silly
i'm thinking thank you he took his legs i'm glad you guys
all enjoyed this playthrough it has been a journey spanning
over three months but we did it guys he couldn't too close
to the sun lali thank you the super chat thank you thank you
that was a few rounds before i always believed in the
wheelchair apple they even super chat they could thank Thank
you, Bom, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Solid, thank you, thank you, thank you.
GG, 62 bird.
It took a few months, but they sure were super fun.
Well done, Jochi.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
The next series, I know we said James Bond, but we need to
finish Onimusha first.
James Bond found it in a ditch somewhere.
But guys, the next series we have to complete is Onimusha,
because there's a million fucking things I need to remember.
about the game a million controls and so most likely next
week it's going to be like at least three three parts of
Onimusha next week I like how I never spent a single I just
ordered all my money because I knew my build was perfect
there was no reason to spend my money after that I've
already created the perfect mech.
Meta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a Raven with Gen 1, you've earned your title of
Ninebreaker.
Good job, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm saving money for Armor Core 7.
Saber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The wheelchair wins again.
This ability prevails.
Just think aside, you're now a true Raven.
Hope this helps you on playing more Armor Core games.
Thank you for the super chat.
I had a lot of fun.
I get it.
Like I said, it was my first armor core game.
So it was definitely, I think it was a perfect game for me
to get into the series.
It was very fun.
The story was really interesting.
I gave everybody unlimited waifus now.
And it was hard.
You know, like there were moments where it was so hard.
And there were moments where, you know, it was just a walk
in the park.
But all, like, I think, like...
Definitely I nerfed myself by playing on mouse and keyboard.
But I'm stubborn.
I did not want to learn new controls, like, at the end.
I really did not.
I was just like, I've already made it this far.
I've already made it this far with M and K.
I might as well see it to the end.
Super.
Thank you for the super chat thinking thing.
Yeah.
Especially after the Onimusha dev shoutout.
Yeah, of course you prioritize Onimusha first.
I think it was super chat thinking thing.
Yeah.
i just think the game is really fun apparently the reviews
for it has been like really high um i mean i definitely i
enjoyed onimusha a lot i the one thing i like i said i miss
the og uh i do miss the og uh play style of onimusha um
because they made onimusha a souls like now but i think
souls like is such a popular genre like i think you know i
think they made it the og's play sound like not a lot of
people would play the game which is understandable because
it's such a outdated um uh i guess like game style i guess
that's how you call it game design is a little up it's it's
such an outdated game design because people don't like
people don't really like tank controllers people don't like
fixed camera angles um but i i there was just something um
just something about it you know it was like very nostalgic
too you know um it was such a nostalgic game for me and um
it was like uniqueness to it i really like but i do like
that they still kept the campiness um yeah because yeah it's
pretty outdated yeah but i like that they kept the campiness
of the writing and like how it doesn't take itself really
seriously and the graphics are beautiful the expressions and
the graphics is really really good um but the game is hard
it's so hard i think it's just because i'm i just i'm i'm um
just really bad at pairing but the window for it is just
really difficult i know like how some people are i saw
people who were complaining yeah i love the humor in in
onimusha too yeah there's just something uh uh special like
there's just like listen only special about onimusha that
holds like a special place in my heart um uh what was i
gonna say oh yeah people were complaining and i saw some
people in comments complaining like why is she using english
uh voice acting um she should play be playing on the
superior japanese voice acting i think it's fine also i
don't want to read i it's harder when you're streaming
because when you're streaming be like accessible to
everybody you won't be accessible to everyone who's watching
and some people just want to listen they don't want to you
know if they're watch if they're like putting on a different
monitor or something like it's more accessible when it's
like in english so they don't have to like look on the
screen to read like you know to like read read all the
dialogue to know what they're saying um and i think the
voice acting is fine i like the voice acting I think it's
funny that, uh, it's like the, the, how, how British it is
and, um, and, yeah, and I just think it, I think it's, I
think like there's some funny moments with the British, with
the British voice acting, and I really enjoy it.
Yeah.
He's really, I think it's really funny, yeah.
I played the original in 3A season and got addicted to Armor
Core 6 after watching streams.
Happy to see you play until the end.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Mike.
Yeah, I think the voice acting is fine.
I enjoyed the British voice acting in Onimusha.
And I think it's like very...
I like making sure my streams are accessible as well to
people who might not be able to, you know, have the time to
read the dialogue during the cutscenes and everything.
Yeah.
And I think it's just a more accessible streaming
experience.
Let's see.
Let's see, what are super chats?
Have I not read yet?
Oh, I'm thinking of a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait, did I read... Oh, I read Apophis, yeah.
I enjoyed watching every bit.
I enjoyed every bit watching you play my favorite Mecha
series.
overall thoughts on the game I liked it I really enjoyed it
um I like that you can customize different type of builds
that suit your playstyle I say as I'd stuck with one change
is hard change is wrong change is bad if it works it works
you know but you know you find your perfect playstyle your
perfect build and just stuck through it um and everything um
and if it ain't broke don't fix it and if it ain't working i
it's not my fault it's not me it's them and i i do it i
enjoyed the gameplay um and the story was really interesting
and the looping factor of it like how it changes a little
every time like when you go back to when you go to new game
plus and a new game plus plus i think it was i think i can
see why um this game is very well loved um and i it was a
very i'm glad that i started this game in the franchise and
uh as my first game into the armor core series
yeah also i agree also the reason why i play with english
dub is because like um i have to balance between reading the
dialogue out to you guys and also letting them talk which is
also like one of the biggest problems when you're playing on
playing a game that's not the english dub um just because
you're like oh um you're like when do when should i read
this so that it doesn't overlap with the japanese dub as
well it doesn't confuse also it helps that i don't have to
read a lot of stuff out loud because i think my throat would
be my my vocal cords would be so fried by today yeah
yeah i think i think like it helps that you know it helps
that i don't have because i've streamed it for six plus
hours so i would read a lot of stuff
um super thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
especially after owning oh yeah i already read that but yeah
i think again mike oh whoops I read that, but thank you
again.
Doug, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I tend to watch the longer streams, audio only while I work
on other stuff, so thank you for picking English dialogue.
Makes audio only possible.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, like I said, I know some people who have streams out
on their second monitor, or they do audio and just listen in
and look back to it whenever they can.
So I want to make sure, like, for people everywhere that
it's accessible for you guys.
That's why I don't play on, uh, that's why I don't play on,
like, you know, uh, I don't play on, like, uh, dubs that
are, like, not, usually not English, just for that reason.
Um, Voita, I'm thinking of the Super Chat, and sometimes I
just, I just find some dubs to be silly, and I like the
silliness, you know?
Sometimes I, some, like, Onimusha, especially Onimusha, the
first Onimusha games were, When you guys watched the
streams, they were pretty funny and pretty silly.
I like that.
I like the whimsy, you know?
The whimsyness it brings.
Boy-Tan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what's a funny coincidence?
Project Hail Mary has coral energy.
Same color, just as destructive to the universe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's interesting.
I didn't realize that.
I forgot.
I forgot the the whole thing was about Kora.
I think everybody was more, well for me, I was more focused
on Ryan Reynolds and his friendship with a talking rock.
Oh, not Ryan Reynolds.
Sorry, I keep Ryan Goslin.
God damn it.
All these goddamn Ryan's.
Sorry, I was too busy with Ryan Goslin and his relationship
with his pet rock.
And I legitimately forgot about the main plot of the movie.
Where they have to figure out what the fuck to do with Koro.
There's too many Ryans in the world.
We gotta do something.
We gotta do something about it.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
Okay, so I haven't unpacked it.
But I saw someone posting photos.
Of the Onimusha package.
Let me show you guys.
I'm gonna steal someone else's tweet for it.
It's so cool.
I didn't unpack it yet because, like, I got lazy and I was
tired.
But look what's actually inside it.
I saw someone posted their PR package.
Look at this.
So cool.
It has a bronze statue.
I think it has to be a bronze statue.
Well, not actual.
Maybe not actual bronze, but it's like fake bronze statue.
It comes with an Onimusha coin.
a brahm musubi statue stolen valley it's so cool i like the
packaging of it like the box packaging with the um they're
so creative
uh lolly thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
like in wukong we're in the end up the headless singing
performing yeah i like it it's just it's just silly it's
funny i like that It's like it's only talking as thick and
then we were like, oh guys, it's okay.
I think he's from Hong Kong
It's a thick Irish accent when he's done Yeah, that's why
sometimes I play on English stuff because I just think it's
like I think it's really is I think it's the whimsyness of
it
But yeah, thank you guys for Being there for three months
three months of armor core took us a while to finish the
game because of everything going on there's always something
that was like something was always happening that made me
delay the series even longer usually i'd be done with a
series within like two to three weeks but so many things
were going on but i'm glad we powered through and we did new
gameplay and we did true ending to um be able to um be able
to experience true ending with all of you guys um and What a
journey.
What a journey it's been.
10 parts of Armor Core.
And we made it, guys.
We made it.
We beat it.
We beat it with maybe, perhaps, one of the shittiest builds
I've possible against.
Well, not the worst builds possible against Iguana.
But it's okay.
We beat them.
We made it possible.
There is worse.
I said one of them
Big boom Exactly But I did it I did it so it's no longer
shitty Because I did it
I didn't need meta builds I play what I want to play I'm a
wheelchair one trick Yeah exactly is that I did it.
All those naysayers are quiet now.
Prove them all wrong.
Anyways, I'm going to call it here.
Thank you all for the support.
Thank you for staying with me to the very end today.
And to the end of this series.
I hope you guys have fun time watching.
I hope you guys have fun time hanging out with me.
And as always, Everybody stay hydrated posture check get up
and move around to get that blood flowing And if you stay up
for me head to bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys
next time everybody Bye guys